chers collègues je vous propose de
commencer cette audition de l'asn sujet
récurrent c'est un des sujets
constitutive de l'opex on le rappelle
sur la question un des sujets que le
péquiste systématiquement suis année
après année cette audition de l'autorité
de sûreté nucléaire pour la présentation
de son rapport annuel est une tradition
et l'actualité nucléaire dans ce rang se
rend ce rendez vous d'autant plus
important monsieur le président monsieur
le directeur général merci pour votre
présence sans plus de formalité je vais
vous donner la parole que vous
organiserez comme vous le souhaitez pour
nous faire une présentation suite à quoi
nous lancerons la série des changes en
accordant une priorité aux quatre
rapporteurs de l'opex d'engager
aujourd'hui dans des missions ayant
trait au nucléaire civil
bruno sido emilie cariou théo thomas
gaci ue et stéphane pieds noirs
monsieur le président à vous la parole
monsieur le président de russie khl il
merci beaucoup monsieur le président il
est le g1 et qu est-ce que vous avez
également un écho nous vous entendons
bien mais oui nous voterons eh bien oui
parfait merci beaucoup c'était quoi a
disparu merci beaucoup merci monsieur le
président monsieur le vice-président
merci mesdames et messieurs les
parlementaires de nous accueillir
aujourd'hui je suis accompagné d'olivier
gupta qui est le directeur général de
l'asn est ainsi que de l'ensemble des
membres du collège et du comité exécutif
de la cen qui sont à distance
cependant en ligne donc nous allons vous
présenter le rapport de l'autorité de
sûreté nucléaire au titre de l'année
2020 et bien évidemment comme vous
l'avait indiqué le président a ensuite
nous répondra à vos questions
alors si vous permettez j'introduirai
l'audition par un propos liminaire
consacré à la période 2020
début 2000 21 que nous avons vécu en
insistant sur les principaux
enseignements et enjeux qui en ressort
olivier gupta vous parlera ensuite de la
manière dont nous avons exercé notre
contrôle pendant cette période ainsi que
les enseignements opérationnel que nous
en tirons à ce stade
puis il évoquera notre contribution aux
travaux techniques internationaux dans
ce contexte inédit aux présentations
liminaires s'articulera autour de deux
constats généraux puis la mise en
évidence de deux faits marquants
le premier constat général qui n'est pas
une surprise et que la crise liée à la
copie de 19 a profondément marqué
l'année 2020 et le début de l'année 2021
durant toute cette période la sp l'asn
estime que le niveau de sûreté et de
radioprotection est resté satisfaisant
face à la crise sanitaire les
exploitants nucléaires et les
responsables d'activités notamment dans
le domaine médical ont fait preuve d'une
grande réactivité et d'une bonne
capacité d'adaptation durant la première
période de confinement les exploitants
nucléaires ont su maîtriser la situation
en mettant en action lors lors du
contenu et les activités non
indispensables ont été suspendues par
exemple et de recherche et responsable
d'activité dans le secteur médical on
peut adapter leur organisation pour
gérer la situation sanitaire est assuré
globalement la permanence des technos
tite et des soins faisant appel aux
techniques mobilisant les rayonnements
ionisants
l'asn à surveiller de près les
conséquences immédiates la crise et
s'agissant des centrales nucléaires et
des installations du site combustible
l'asn n'a pas constaté de dégradation du
niveau de sûreté liées à la crise ni
pendant la période initiale de
confinement ni par la suite
le report de nombreuses activités
intervenue au printemps 2020 a conduit à
une situation tendue qui perdurent
notamment chez edf les arrêts des
réacteurs qui avait dû être décalée ont
été reprogrammés et certaines forêts se
sont réalisées durant la période
hivernale comme ce sera le cas
d'ailleurs pour l'hiver 2021 2022
ce qui crée effectivement des tensions
sur l'approvisionnement en énergie
électrique pour l'ensemble de notre pays
cette reprogrammation et les effets
domino elle induit sur les années à
venir crée également des tensions en
matière de mobilisation des prestataires
et de respect des obligations de
contrôle de chaque acte dans le
nucléaire médical
l'asn n'a pas constaté d'augmentation
des événements significatifs de
radioprotection lors du regain
d'activité après le premier confinement
et la gestion des situations de crise
sur la dure elle a cependant soulevé
dans certains cas des questions en
matière de radioprotection des patients
liées au manque de disponibilité ou à la
cherche surcharge de travail est
professionnel baby face aux
bouleversements induits par la crise
sanitaire
l'asn a engagé une réflexion sur ses
propres modalités de propofol dont
olivier guitta vous parlera alors mais
l'asn a également engagé une réflexion
sur les questions de nature systémique
qui pourraient se poser dans les mêmes
termes en cas de crise nucléaire
c'est le cas par exemple de la confiance
des citoyens dans la parole de l'expert
et des autorités
mais c'est aussi la question des
conditions d'élaboration est
acceptabilité sur le terrain des mesures
contraignantes de protection des
populations prises par les pouvoirs
publics en cas de situation de crise
nucléaire
ces réflexions ont été engagés par l'asn
dans le cadre des travaux du comité
directeur pour la gestion de la phase
post-accidentelle aux dires
à qui est un groupe pluraliste créée en
2005 elle pilote et du nouveau mandat
elle a reçu du premier ministre suspens
ce domaine est saine estime que le
retour d'expérience de la crise
sanitaire et les travaux du codirpa mené
avec l'appui de relais locaux comme
celui des commissions locales
d'information constitueront des éléments
clés pour progresser plus globalement
enfin l'asn estime que les premières
analyses tirées des difficultés
rencontrées lors de la crise sanitaire
confirme le besoin impératif qu'elle a
régulièrement souligné d'entretenir une
culture d'anticipation et de précaution
pour l'ensemble des acteurs du nucléaire
illustration de deux faits marquants par
la suite me permettra d'y revenir
second constat général que je voudrais
souligner concerne les résultats de
sûreté et de radioprotection
ils sont globalement en amélioration en
2020 chez edf par exemple
l'asn considère que la rigueur
d'exploitation qui était un sujet que
j'avais souligné l'année dernière à
progresser avec une meilleure
surveillance en salle de commande un
pilotage plus rigoureux des
installations et l'amélioration de la
gestion des écarts affectant les
installations les évolutions
d'organisation et report d'activité liée
à la crise sanitaire ou l'évolution des
comportements induits par la crise
notamment une meilleure présence des
managers sur le terrain une plus grande
attention à la réalisation des travaux
une pression moindre en ce qui concerne
la durée des arrêts ont pu contribuer à
cette amélioration
fiorano l'asn a constaté le maintien
d'un bon niveau de sûreté pour
l'ensemble de ses installations avec la
poursuite des efforts de rigueur pour
maîtriser les enjeux de confinement et
de radioprotection à l'issue de la
démarche expérimentale que nous avons
menées en 2019
d'inspection sur les projets notamment
les projets la conduite des projets de
démantèlement et de reprise
conditionnement des déchets anciens
nous avons noté en 2020 une amélioration
dans l'organisation de ces projets qui
devraient conduire à une plus grande
robustesse dans leur gestion au cea
l'asn considère que la sûreté des
installations demeure globalement
satisfaisante dans un contexte
d'activité qui a été moins comme je vais
souligné tout à l'heure et souligner le
travail en matière de renforcement de la
culture de sûreté est responsable d'un
site à l'action donc été menée par le
ceva au vu du retour d'expérience des
instruments
ces quelques constats viennent cependant
à quelques constats pardon viennent
cependant nuancé cette appréciation
générale qui est positive pour les
exploitants nucléaires chez edf l'asn a
constaté une régression dans la prise en
compte de la radioprotection pour les
travailleurs régression qui avait déjà
été observé en 2019 mais qui s'est
accentuée en 2001 ainsi que la
persistance écart de conformité
affectant des matériels qui auraient
remis en cause la capacité à remplir
leur fonction en cas d'accident ces cas
par exemple des nombreuses et cartons
étaient encore détecté sur les groupes
électrogènes de secours à moteur diesel
chez aura nos l'asn constatent les
améliorations encore trop lente pour
certaines installations dans la gestion
du risque incendie et une vigilance à
maintenir sur la reprise et le
conditionnement des déchets anciens pour
permettre le respect des délais prévus
par la loi en 2010 et au ca
l'asn souligne des retards manifeste
dans la mise en oeuvre de la stratégie
de démantèlement des installations
anciennes présentant des risques les
plus élevés sur laquelle les scènes et
la snd s'était prononcé en 2019
enfin termes de bilan dans le domaine
médical
malgré des résultats satisfaisants au
regard du nombre d'actes
l'asn relève encore des défaillances
organisationnelles et techniques très
peu nombreuses mais évitables comme les
erreurs de côté les erreurs de
fractionnement de doses
les mauvais paramétrage de logiciels à
l'origine d'événements significatifs en
radiothérapie de niveau 2 ou 3 c'est à
dire ayant des effets aigus ou tardif
pour les patients voilà pour les
constats généraux ils termineraient ma
présentation en soulignant deux faits
marquants pour la période 2020 début
début 2000 21 qui illustre la nécessité
d'entretenir et de développer la culture
d'anticipation et de concussion
c'est avant tout d'abord la la période
récente a été marquée par une décision
importante de l'asm
concernant la poursuite d'exploitation
des réacteurs de 900 mégawatts à l'issue
d'un long travail qui a démarré en 2013
et qui est fortement sollicité l'asn
l'irsn et les équipes d'edf le volet
générique quatrième réexamen des
réacteurs de 900 mégawatts d'edf a
débouché sur la définition
d'amélioration significative la sûreté
et sur une décision de l'asn prise le 23
février 2021
ces améliorations concernant en
particulier la maîtrise des risques liés
aux agressions comme l' incendie
l'explosion l'inondation le séisme par
exemple la sûreté des piscines
d'entreposage des combustibles et la
gestion des accidents avec fusion de
l'asn a estimé que ces améliorations
permettait d'ouvrir la perspective une
poursuite de fonctionnement des
réacteurs de 900 mégawatts pour les dix
ans pour les dix ans suivant leur quatre
oui ceux des femmes parce que il ya
mutex un petit nous avons un petit
parasite alliance c'est bon ok famille
excusez-nous monsieur le président c'est
juste un petit présent climat sa soeur
je vous en prie donc je disais que l'asn
a estimé en février dernier au vu de ces
améliorations que il était possible
d'ouvrir la perspective de poursuite de
fonctionnement des réacteurs de 900
mégawatts pour les dix ans suivant leur
quatrième examen période cette poursuite
de fonctionnement sera à confirmer pour
chacun des réacteurs
à l'issue de leur visite décennale qui a
déjà démarré mais qui s'étalera pour les
32 réacteurs concernés jusqu'à 2000 31
mai le réexamen de sûreté des réacteurs
d'edf a soulevé deux points de vigilance
que je souhaiterais évoqué devant tout
d'abord la question de la capacité
industrielle d'edf et des intervenants
de la filière à faire face aux travaux
ils sont issus du réexamen avec un
niveau de qualité attendu
l'ensemble des travaux de grand carénage
prévu par edf qui va qui vont au de loin
au delà pardon des travaux
d'amélioration de sûreté prévue par à
l'examen mais qui les inclut bien
évidemment conduira à augmenter
notablement la charge de travail
industriels de la filière avec une
attention particulière apportée sur
certains segments en tension comme la
mécanique ou l'algérie temps jeux
l'exploitant que chez les opérateurs
les travaux connaîtront des sept années
d'une montée en puissance importante
avec 4 réexamen de sûreté a réalisé en
2021 et un pic d'activité industrielle
en 2026 edf estime par exemple que la
charge de travail des secteurs du génie
civil et du coton du contrôle commande
sera multiplié par trois dans les cinq
années qui viennent y ait dans le
secteur de la mécanique
cette charge sera multiplié par 3,6
alors que ce segment a connu quelques
difficultés ces dernières années pour
arriver au niveau de qualité attendu
notamment
dans le domaine du soudage alors si les
perspectives de montée en charge des
travaux sur le parc existant constitué
un point de vigilance s'est également
bien évidemment une opportunité pour la
filière nucléaire il a souffert par le
passé de l'absence de projet et donc de
travaux en volume suffisant pour
entretenir ses compétences et l'asn
voudrais souligner que dans la période
actuelle
une attention particulière doit être
portée à certains acteurs clés de la
filière nucléaire qui peuvent aussi être
exposé dans d'autres secteurs de haute
technologie comme par exemple
aéronautique dans lesquelles ils
travaillent également mais il faut
également porter une certaine attention
restructuration d'ensemble de certains
grands groupes qui ont décidé de se
retirer de l'activité nucléaire
c'est le premier point de vigilance je
voulais souligner et il s'est traduit
dans la décision de l'asn par une
demande spécifique c'est la première
fois que nous formions une telle demande
de rendre compte annuellement de la
capacité à faire des industriels de la
filière pour pouvoir assurer les travaux
qui résulte des prescriptions que nous
avons prises dans le courrier que nous
avons déjà le second point de vigilance
qui ressort du réexamen de sûreté des
réacteurs d'edf est à plus long terme et
il concerne l'articulation avec la
politique énergétique
un des enseignements tirés du réexamen
des réacteurs de 900 mégawatts
tf concerne le caractère déterminant et
justifications n'ont été apportées pour
la tenue des pubs dont le matériau subi
une dégradation de ses caractéristiques
mécaniques du fait leur exposition aux
rayonnements et justifications plan pu
être apportée par edf à ce stade
concernent la période de dix ans à venir
ces justifications de sont probantes et
c'est la raison pour laquelle l'asn a
pris une décision positive concernant
les dix années à venir
mais edf n'a transmis à ce stade
qu'un dossier de justification jusqu'à
50 ans c'est à dire pour cette période
de dix années supplémentaires
et ce dossier montre que plusieurs
réacteurs ne disposent que très peu de
marge pour un fonctionnement au delà de
50 ans et pour justifier la tenue des
cuves d'un maximum de ses réacteurs
jusqu'à 60 ans la période suivante par
exemple edf devra faire évoluer sa
méthode de justification en s'appuyant
sur des travaux de recherche pour
réduire un certain en service
l'aboutissement de telle démarche n'est
aucunement garanti et le point principal
de préoccupation pour les scènes c'est
celui de l'horizon 2040
c'est à dire le moment où la durée de
fonctionnement des réacteurs les plus
anciens du parc nucléaire atteindra
entre 50 et 60 ans dans les années qui
précéderont cet horizon si les
perspectives de développement de
nouvelles capacités de production telles
qu'elles sont prévues ou qu'elles seront
prévues par la prochaine les pe n'était
pas au rendez vous et si les gains
attendus en matière d'efficacité
énergétique et des pas suffisant la
tentation pourrait être de vouloir
prolonger la durée d'exploitation des
réacteurs en service pour disposer d'un
socle de production électrique pilotable
non carbonées suffisant
rien ne permet aujourd'hui de garantir
que ce sera possible et dans ce contexte
nous estimons qu'il est absolument
nécessaire d'anticiper
il est absolument nécessaire que la
décision de prolongation ou pas de
fonctionnement de certains réacteurs
à cette échéance 2040 soit anticipée
fasse l'objet d'études et âme pour
qu'elle ne soit pas une décision subi le
moment venu compte tenu des délais qui
sont nécessaires à l'aboutissement de
toutes nouvelles démarches de
justification et des délais pour décider
et réaliser de nouveaux projets
éventuellement en substitution
quels qu'ils soient et conviendrait de
poser dès à présent dans le cadre de la
prochaine et pe la question de la durée
de fonctionnement des réacteurs en
exploitation de manière transparente et
réaliste pour pouvoir anticiper les
décisions à prendre et maintenir des
marges suffisantes pour la sûreté second
et dernier fait marquant pour la période
de 2021
début 2009 les bulles ou pardon 2020
début 2000 21 que je souhaiterais
évoqués concernent la gestion des
matières et des déchets radioactifs
le cinquième plan national de gestion
des matières et des déchets radioactifs
valable pour une période de cinq ans est
en cours de préparation dans ce cadre
l'asn a émis en 2020 et début 2000 21
plusieurs avis organisé par filières de
gestion sur lesquels nous pourrons
revenir si vous le souhaitez mais
l'enjeu principal qui ressort de manière
transversale à ces différences d'avis et
celui de l'urgence à choisir et à la
encore anticipé si les plans précédents
ont permis de développer de nombreuses
études de partager avec les parties
prenantes à grand nombre de données et
de résultats d'études pour faire un état
des lieux des solutions possibles il
s'agit maintenant selon nous d'avancer
concrètement pour la mise en oeuvre de
ces deux solutions dans ces filières
dans ces habiles la scène souligne que
c'est notamment le cas pour les déchets
très faiblement radioactifs tf1
ferraille gravats était essentiellement
d'ombré pour lesquels les capacités de
stockage existantes seront saturées
d'ici 2028 ou 2035 selon les options à
l'étude
l'asn souligné que c'est également le
cas pour les déchets est fa-vl qui
regroupe un ensemble hétérogène de
déchets anciens comme les déchets de
graphite
cherradi cher encore les déchets et hume
et pour lesquels aucune solution claire
de gestion n'a été arrêtée à ce stade
c'est le cas en fin du projet à 6 géo
de stockage en couche géologique
profonde qui des déchets à haute
activité vie longue qui reste un projet
controversé
bien qu'il soit le résultat d'un long
processus législatif ayant ouvert la
réflexion et d'union concertation sur le
choix de cette option dessous nuage qui
est préconisé au niveau international au
regard des risques et la durée du
stockage pour l'asn clairement le
prochain plan pour la durée de cinq ans
devra être celui du choix des solutions
pour faire face dans vingt ans dans les
20 ans qui viennent aux besoins
capacitaires de stockage des déchets
générés par les opérations de
démantèlement
la reprise et le conditionnement des
déchets et la poursuite d'exploitation
nucléaire
nous savons le nucléaire et le domaine
du temps long les projets demandent un
temps conséquent de l'ordre d'une
quinzaine d'années avant de pouvoir être
opérationnel
après qu'il ait été décidé et donc il
faut que d'ici 2025 les décisions soient
prises sur les solutions à mettre en
oeuvre
si nous voulons pouvoir faire face à
l'horizon 2040 aux nécessités de
stockage des déchets tous types de
déchets en france par ailleurs et c'est
le dernier point à plus long terme
concernant les matières radioactives
l'asn estime dans ses avis une approche
prudente de la qualification en tant que
matière devraient être retenus notamment
lorsque les perspectives de valorisation
ne sont pas réalistes et que la
prochaine ppe devra se positionner sur
la question de la poursuite ou pas du
retraitement des combustibles usés
au delà de 2040 qui est la date qui
figure actuellement dans la pp quelle
que soit la décision crise il faudra en
effet anticiper ses conséquences là
encore d'une quinzaine d'années si leur
traitement est prolongée aura nos deux
va construire de nouvelles installations
ou remettre significativement à niveau
celle existant
comme le fait edf par exemple pour le
grand carénage de ses réacteurs et s'il
est décidé de l'arrêter leur traitement
il faudra anticiper des conditions
d'entreposage et les dimensions du
stockage multi l'exemple de la piscine
du projet de piscine centralisée
d'entreposage des combustibles usés et
edf qui avait été identifiée comme
nécessaires et 2010 et qui devait être
opérationnel en 2030 et qu edf annonce
aujourd'hui disponible en 2034 montre la
nécessité de largement anticipé ces
sujets voilà monsieur le président
monsieur le vice-président et mesdames
et messieurs les parlementaires les
points du rapport annuel que je voulais
souligner et si vous le permettez je
passe la parole à olivier guy à pour
compléter
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
directeur général avant le tour merci
monsieur le président sur le vice
président mesdames et messieurs les
parlementaires
vous nous aviez interrogé au printemps
dernier sur l'activité de l'asn dans le
contexte de crise sanitaire et je
commencerai donc par vous rendre compte
de l'exécution de nos missions en 2020
et des premiers enseignements que nous
en tirons que nous tirons de la
situation actuelle
et puis alors où il est beaucoup
question d'europe en matière de vaccins
je vous parlerai d'un sujet qui me tient
personnellement à coeur c'est
l'harmonisation de la sûreté nucléaire à
l'échelle européenne
premier point la crise sanitaire
nous sommes maintenant plus d'un an
après le début de cette crise et je peux
vous confirmer que nous avons réussi à
faire ce que nous devions faire malgré
les périodes de confinement et en
particulier nous avons réalisé les
contrôles que nous estimions nécessaire
compte tenu de la situation dans les
installations nucléaires et dans les
hôpitaux pour être précis cela
représente mais 5573 inspections sur
l'année 2020 si nous avons pu assurer
correctement nos missions c'est bien sûr
grâce à l'engagement de l'ensemble des
personnels de l'asn et permettez moi de
les saluer ici mais c'est aussi grâce
aux moyens que nous avons obtenus avec
votre soutien et avec celui du
gouvernement
je pense bien sûr aux aux moyens
financiers et en particulier à des
dépenses qui avaient pu être vu comme
superflus avant la crise mais qui se
sont avérés essentiels nous en donne un
exemple à la fin de l'année 2019
nous avions investi pour une somme qui
est restée relativement modeste mais qui
nous a permis de raccorder les postes
informatiques de nos divisions
territoriales directement au réseau
informatique du siège et sans le
meilleur débit de données qui a permis
ce raccordement la moitié des personnels
de l'asn ne l'aurait pas pu travailler à
distance pendant les confinements alors
je pense aussi évidemment aux renforts
que nous avions obtenus en matière
d'effectifs ces dernières années parce
que ce sont ces renforts qui nous ont
permis de disposer à temps des
personnels formés et compétents pour
préparer dans le calendrier prévu
notre prise de position générique sur la
poursuite d'exploitation des réacteurs
de 900 mégawatts mais aussi c'est moins
sur le devant de la scène pour
rendre par exemple la réglementation du
nucléaire de proximité mieux
proportionnée aux enjeux de la
radioprotection
il ya aussi un aspect matériel en
quelque sorte qui nous a été très
précieux pendant cette crise et que nous
nous attachons à préserver
c'est la culture commune des personnels
de la spn interrogative l'attachement
aux valeurs et à la mission qui est la
nôtre notre capacité aussi à faire
émerger collectivement des décisions je
crois que c'est cette culture commune
qui nous a permis de travailler ensemble
sans être ensemble alors quelles
premières leçons pouvons-nous tirer de
cette situation sur nos modalités de
contrôle
d'abord je dirais l'importance d'avoir
un contrôle que je qualifie de
responsabilisant
nous avons salué la capacité
d'adaptation des acteurs du nucléaire
face à cette crise
que ce soit le nucléaire industriel ou
nucléaire médical et notre contrôle doit
préserver absolument cette capacité
d'adaptation
je pense que c'est le cas aujourd'hui
mais c'est certainement un point auquel
nous devons veiller parce que la pente
naturelle est inverse en incident à
peine une règle de plus qu'ils ne se
reproduisent plus et c'est notre
tentation naturelle mais c'est aussi ce
vers quoi les différentes parties
prenantes nous nous pousse or la sûreté
ce n'est pas que des règles c'est des
règles bien sûr mais c'est aussi en
quelque sorte l'intelligence des
situations la capacité d'adaptation
carmen des différents acteurs en temps
réel pour peu qu'ils aient suffisamment
de marge de manoeuvre
un contrôle responsabilisant bien
entendu il va de pair avec un dialogue
technique franc et approfondi entre
l'asm et différents exploitants chaque
clan dans son rôle naturellement nous
avons eu tout au long de l'année 2020 un
dialogue de bonne qualité avec tous les
grands exploitants y compris avec et df
je le souligne parce que ça n'avait pas
toujours été le cas par le passé
ça s'est avéré très précieux en
particulier pendant la crise tiani père
et puis au delà de la crise sanitaire le
contexte actuel je pense révèle
l'importance de la prise en compte des
questions économiques et industrielles
dans le ciblage de nos actions contrôle
dans un souci d'anticipation
c'est ce que nous faisons et je vous en
donne un exemple bernard derosier qui
évoquait tout à l'heure les tensions sur
les capacités industrielles de
l'ensemble des entreprises sous
traitantes et les dans certains secteurs
en particulier
bien sûr ce point nous avons programmé
dès cette année plusieurs inspections
chez des fournisseurs qui sont en
situation de monopole vis-à-vis ddm
voilà pour les premiers enseignements
que nous tirons de cette période
j'en viens maintenant au second point de
mon propos et vous serez peut-être
surpris que je vous parle d'
internationale alors que les
déplacements à l'étranger sont encore
très fortement restreint et les slaves
depuis un an et demi mais il y a eu des
avancées en particulier à l'échelle
européenne dans le cadre de
l'association des responsables
d'autorités de sûreté nucléaire d'europe
dont l'acronyme en anglais et when he à
cette association a été créée il ya une
vingtaine d'années pour bâtir une
approche commune de la sûreté nucléaire
en europe et l'asn a ya toujours joué un
rôle moteur et il se trouve que j'ai été
élu président de cette association fin
2019 et nous avons cette année fait des
avancées sur plusieurs points ou aidera
avait publié en 2010 des objectifs de
sûreté pour les nouveaux réacteurs
ses objectifs étaient d'ailleurs très
largement inspiré de ce que la externe a
fixé pour le réacteur européenne mènera
s'était engagé à les réexaminer au bout
de dix ans pour tenir compte si
nécessaire du progrès des connaissances
donc cet examen a été fait vient de se
conclure et à l'issue de notre dernière
réunion plénière
nous avons adopté la position suivante
qui vient tout juste d'être publié
premièrement ces objectifs de sûreté
pour les nouveaux réacteurs sont
toujours valides sont toujours au goût
du jour
ils sont toujours applicable au futur
réacteur nucléaire et deuxièmement tels
qu'ils sont formulées ils sont aussi
applicables au petit réacteur modulaire
c'est un sujet qu'il connaît un regain
d'attention en france et à l'étranger
ce sujet des petit réacteur modulaire et
pour ces petits réacteurs donc les smr
ces objectifs sont seulement un minimum
à atteindre parce qu'au regard du
potentiel de ce genre de technologie les
exigences de sûreté plus importante
pourrait être attendue
voilà la position qui vient d'être prise
et nous comptons sur cette base
poursuivre nos travaux pour définir des
exigences communes l échelle européenne
sur c'est petit réacteur modulaire
alors au delà des ces objectifs généraux
de sûreté ou nras a développé depuis une
vingtaine d'années des normes
harmonisées donc à l'échelle européenne
que nous appelons niveau de référence de
sûreté nous les élèves auront en commun
et ensuite nous en vérifiant ensemble la
transcription
j'utilise ce terme à dessein la
transcription dans nos réglementations
nationales même s'il n'ya pas
d'obligation juridique d'ailleurs parce
que tout cela repose sur un engagement
volontaire de chacun d'entre nous à
mettre en oeuvre ces niveaux de
référence de sûreté dans nos
réglementations nationales et je dirais
presque que c'est justement parce qu'il
n'ya pas d'obligation juridique que ça
fonctionne que nous parvenons à des
consensus et que nous arrivons ensuite
allé transcrire je repense le terme dans
les réglementations nationales nous
avons de tels niveaux de référence pour
les centrales nucléaires
et justement nous en avons publié une
mise à jour à la fin de l'année 2020
tenant compte des derniers
développements de l'état de l'art en
matière de sûreté nucléaire
nous en avons aussi en matière de
démantèlement et de gestion des déchets
et puis nous en avons publié
et en 2021 un nouveau un nouvel ensemble
donc deux niveaux de référence pour les
réacteurs de recherche ou aidera à
susciter un intérêt au delà même de
l'europe puisque depuis quelques années
des paysans européens comme la russie le
canada et le japon part à nos réunions
et certainement une forme de
reconnaissance de nos travaux et donc je
dirais qu'au total depuis une vingtaine
d'années il s'est construit pas à pas
une doctrine de sûreté des règles de
sûreté harmonisée à l'échelle européenne
et ce qui est tout à fait singulier
c'est que ce n'est pas la commission
européenne qui est le porteur principal
de cela ce sont réellement les autorités
de sûreté nationale elle-même et se
plaint de pareilles essentielle pour
préparer l'avenir parce qu'au fond ce
que ce travail montre c'est que les
autorités de sûreté des différents pays
de l'union sont capables d'harmoniser
leurs exigences sans abandonner leurs
responsabilités nationales
et si jamais il devait y avoir une
intégration plus forte l'asm n'aura pu
par ce travail au sein de l'inra exercer
une réellement une influence sur les
pratiques et les normes à l'échelle
européenne
voilà ce que je souhaitais vous vous
dire sur sur ce point ça conclut mon
intervention et je pense que je vous
remercie d'abord de votre attention et
je pense que nous sommes maintenant
prêts à répondre à vos questions
merci beaucoup monsieur le directeur
général chez olivier gupta
allons-y je vais commencer je vais
commencer dans cette dans cet échange
par relayer une question du sénateur
pieds noirs qui a dû s'éclipser il ya
quelques minutes pour un engagement en
séance au sénat et qui donc je transmets
la question de sa part le 5 mai dernier
vous déclariez que les petits réacteur
modulaire présente potentiellement des
avancées très significatives en termes
de sûreté
ça fait qu est ce que vous nous
expliquer il ya quelques instants le jeu
le directeur général avait invité le
gouvernement à étudier cette option
comme alternative à le pr2 temps
soulignant son coup probablement
supérieur
quels sont les actes ou du secteur en
termes de sûreté en qu'est ce qu'on peut
en parler parler davantage du fond sur
la sûreté et puis en termes de
calendrier la fin du développement du
smr français donc de ces petits réacteur
modulaire étant prévue au mieux en 2030
n'est-il pas trop tard compte tenu de
l'âge du parc pour l'envisager
c'est la question donc transmises au nom
de stéphane pieds-noirs jeu pour
continuer je passe la parole donc en
priorité aux autres parlementaires
présents sur le parlementaire sur le
rapporteur alors un coup sénat un coup
assemblée la parole à emilie carew
députés merci beaucoup monsieur le
président alors monsieur le président de
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire monsieur
le directeur
merci donc pour cette présentation de
votre rapport annuel qui est toujours
très attendue et que je trouve toujours
en demi teinte c'est à dire que d'une
part vous fait part d'un certain nombre
d'améliorations vous avez prononcé ces
mots il ya une amélioration de la
gestion de la sûreté
mais en même temps quand on vous écoute
on est quand même assez inquiet sur la
question de l'avenir et des travaux à
venir et là notamment vous alerter et ça
fait maintenant quatre ans sous cette
mandature qu'on vous auditionne vous
alerter tous les ans sur la nécessité de
disposer du personnel nécessaire pour la
réalisation des travaux à venir
et là dessus on a toujours l'impression
qu'on est en train de piloter à vue et
on ne voit pas de stratégie
ministérielle qui inclurait bien
évidemment d'enseignement supérieur et
la recherche pour être à même d'assurer
ses travaux avec le personnel nécessaire
alors est ce que vous pourriez nous dire
quelles sont l'état des réflexions d'un
point de vue beaucoup plus stratégique
pour pouvoir disposer du personnel
nécessaire pour réaliser des travaux à
venir concernant notamment ses travaux
sur la prolongation des réacteurs alors
vous nous dites il va falloir quand même
se poser la question et anticiper ce
qu'on veut faire des réacteurs lesquels
on prolonge et de quelle manière même si
là on s'achemine déjà sur les travaux
sous les 32 réacteurs alors avec le
sénateur sido vous savez que nous sommes
chargés du plan de l'estimation et du
rapport parlementaire sur le plan
national de gestion des matières et des
déchets radioactifs
je signale que ce plan à deux ans de
retard alors vous nous avez dit
effectivement c'est tous les cinq ans
maintenant qu'il doit être produit par
le gouvernement le problème c'est que à
vrai dire qu'il devait être produit tous
les trois ans que le gouvernement n'a
pas respecté la loi que du coup il a
prolongé le délai de deux ans il n'en
demeure pas moins que cette loi n'étant
pas rétroactive j'estime qu'aujourd'hui
on est en violation de la loi ce qui ne
permet pas aux parlementaires d'estimé
dans un délai suffisant ce plan et je
pense que si on n'arrive pas à produire
un rapport d'évaluation du plan national
de gestion des déchets des matières
radioactives dans ce quinquennat c'est
quand même extrêmement problématique
quant au contrôle parlementaire et à la
transparence sur les sujets nucléaire
alors donc dans le cadre de ses travaux
avec le sénateur si tôt on a auditionné
récemment des personnes qui nous alerte
sur sur le niveau de sûreté des cuves
des réacteurs alors j'aimerais que vous
nous disiez ce que vous en pensez
puisque ce qui nous a été dit c'est que
certains réacteurs
aujourd'hui
subi service un vieillissement accéléré
accélérée d acier et qui a des clics et
que ce vieillissement pouvait atteindre
la sûreté de certains réacteurs et
notamment trois qui sont pu partir en
problématique est le plus problématique
étant selon les dires des personnes
auditionnées celui de tricastin
donc est ce qu'à un moment donné est on
sûr qu'il faille prolonger les 32
réacteurs
est ce que il n'a il n'est pas plus
avantageux sur le plan économique et de
sûreté finalement deux en plongée que
certains pour pouvoir assumer les coûts
assumés aussi en termes de gestion de
charge de travail
et puis aussi garantir une certaine sur
t d est ce que vous pourriez nous dire
votre avis sur la question
voilà sur le psg mdr donc ce que je vous
en ai déjà parlé donc nous on est quand
même assez on est assez embêté de ne pas
avoir ce plan puisque là en fait on
travaille en parallèle de ski des
travaux qui sont réalisés avec le
gouvernement d'une part le ministère et
puis toutes les autorités concernées
cela étant ce que ce que je vois ce que
vous soulignez là c'est qu'on a un
certain nombre de matières de déchets
qui aujourd'hui n'ont pas de solutions
de gestion et que ce plan il est
absolument nécessaire pour pouvoir
anticiper cela donc je vais m'arrêter là
pour mes questions je vais laisser mes
collègues complété merci beaucoup cher
collègue émilie cargo a mentionné la
mission qu'elle est en train de mener
avec le sénateur bruno sido sur la
gestion des déchets et matières
nucléaires
donc c'est l'occasion justement de
passer la parole au sénateur sido pour
la suite de cette interrogation 200
interrogatoire pardon merci monsieur le
président bonjour monsieur le président
belles scènes chers collègues je
voudrais dire déjà que je partage tout à
fait ce nous bien de dire madame la
député émile caillou c'est quand même un
vrai problème que l'on soit depuis
maintenant plus d'un an sur ce linge
nder pour donner notre avis alors alors
même qu'il n'est pas encore publié et
même finalisé il ya quand même un vrai
problème mais ça nous empêche pas de
travailler
alors concernant ce pnd mais vous ne
dites pas je 369 je crois que l'arrêté
du 15 janvier 2016 qui prévoit la mise à
jour et des coûts de l'enfouissement des
déchets peu après la publication de
l'arrêté c'est qu'on est estimé à la
louche
si je peux dire à 25 milliards d'euros
le temps n'est-il pas venu d'une
réévaluation dans quelles proportions la
réversibilité du stockage également
rappelées dans le document
affecte-t-elle sait où tracer une
question qui concerne le penven des airs
mais plus généralement je voudrais vous
poser d'autres questions la scène à
plusieurs reprises alerté par le passé
sur la nécessité de disposer de marges
suffisantes de production d'électricité
pour faire face à une éventuelle
décision d'arrêt de plusieurs réacteurs
en particulier les recteurs 900
mégawatts et militaires y ont
parfaitement raison de rappeler qu il
semble qu'il y ait des vrais problèmes
sur les pieux si vous pouvez nous en
dire un peu plus sur cette pub des 900
millions et pas les autres
les 900 mégawatts
vu leur âge bien anthony alors cet
avertissement que vous avez donné qu il
toujours d'actualité et la montée en
puissance de l'éolien du solaire et des
interconnexions avec nos voisins
construit tout elle pour vous une
réponse adaptée
autre question le 23 février dernier
l'asm a pris position sur les conditions
au générique de la poursuite des
fonctionnements des 900 mégawatts
j'ai posé les questions donc je
n'assiste pas mais j'aimerais bien que
vous disiez parce qu'on a eu à
l'occasion d'une audition
on est sorti un peu du pngmdr est un
spécialiste dont je ne citerai pas le
nom nous a interpellé sur la question de
la sûreté de ses cuves ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire plus et enfin
dernière question est ce que vous
pourriez nous fait le poids à date sur
le p r de flamanville notamment au
regard de la réparation des soudures et
des circuits et s'épuise secondaire et
principaux pour lesquelles vous avez
accepté le 22 mars 2021
une réparation téléopéré donc quel est
l'impact des problèmes identifiés sur
les aux personnes hors des échines wa
quels sont les étapes restant à franchir
avant la mise en service de ce réacteur
de flamanville
l'objectif d'une entrée en service
l'année prochaine est il réaliste
merci merci chers collègues je passe la
parole maintenant au député thomas gets
you qui est lui co-rapporteur avec
stéphane pieds noirs d'une mission sur
nucléaire également si monsieur le
président émersion maison directeur de
l'asn pour la présentation de leur
rapport annuel et vraiment je vais
remercier également pour leur vigilance
sur le sur le temps long qui est qu'il
est précieuse alors effectivement comme
l'a dit le résident en ville à lire les
missions qu'on sur les conséquences de
l'arrêt d'afrique qui m'amène
naturellement à vous poser une question
sur le sujet et notamment sur la
question de l'uranium appauvri puisque
cette mission nous a rappelé l'intérêt
de conserver ses réserves
radié magori compte tenu de leur faible
dangerosité a priori leurs faibles coûts
de stockage ou d'entreposage et au
contraire du potentiel et énergique
important qui pourrait être permis
notamment avec les réacteurs de nouvelle
génération qui nous font dire que ces
réserves ont une dimension stratégique
voilà pour autant force est de constater
que ses volumes de stocks sont
importants et donc j'aimerais vous poser
la question s'agissant des critères
définis par l'asn
si ils ont prévu la possibilité de
rétrocéder certaines de ces matières
pourquoi je parle de l'uranium appauvri
à certains pays qui serait soucieux de
se constituer une réserve stratégique de
long terme et puis peut-être deux
questions beaucoup plus globale est
beaucoup plus large
j'aimerais vous interroger sur le lien
qui peut exister entre le niveau de
sûreté et le rythme de construction
puisque le chantier le père flamanville
a bien mis en évidence le risque de
perte de compétences associées à un
moindre rythme de construction
donc est-ce que vous avez étudié ce
sujet là j'allais dire à la fois en flux
de construction mais également en stock
je me pose la question au final s'il n'y
a pas un risque de sûreté au fait de
trop diminué la part du nucléaire dans
notre mix énergétique avec une
diminution qui pourrait conduire à fait
c'est notre note globale en la matière
et puis une dernière question si je peux
me permettre monsieur le président bon
là je prends vraiment un recul au niveau
mondial dans le cadre de la lutte contre
le réchauffement climatique le nucléaire
est une option intéressante notamment
pour remplacer les centrales à charbon
et disposer d'une source pilotable l'on
voit bien que ça ne peut pas être tout à
fait généralisée puisque pour le simple
remplacement des centrales à charbon
d'ici 2050 il faudrait construire je
crois de l'ordre de 2000 réacteurs soit
un rythme que l'humanité sans doute ne
sera pas faire je crois que dans la
période la plus prospère du nucléaire on
construisait de lors d'une vingtaine de
réacteurs
chaque année donc on voit qu'il faudrait
plus de 100 ans pour le faire alors
qu'on est dans le cadre d'une urgence
climatique et j'ai été interpellé
récemment aux parades
un chercheur que je questionnais
concernant la fusion nucléaire et je lui
dis alors la fusion nucléaire c'est
pendant 50 ans dans 100 ans dont 150 ans
et il m'a répondu
la fusion nucléaire sera disponible
qu'en l'humanité en
a besoin et donc j'aimerais finalement
vous vous posez la question qu'on puisse
y vient de confirmer que vu de l'asm la
fusion nucléaire est bien le graal que
ce soit en matière de faible risque de
production haut de faible production des
déchets et si finalement vous vous
estimez que nos efforts sont suffisants
en la matière et si vous avez de votre
côté vu de l'asm une aidé des masses
financières qui serait nécessaire pour
développer cette cette fusion afin
d'aboutir au nucléaire il yal sans
risquer sa production de lait merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup chers collègues
je vais y rajouter mes propres questions
ou des prolongements des questions qui
ont déjà qu'ils ont déjà été évoqués
tout d'abord pour faire un point une des
questions qui ont été posées concernent
l'état actuel du dossier flamanville qui
s'est invité à de nombreuses reprises
dans nos éditions
est-ce qu'on peut aussi faire un point
sur la question sur un autre de ses qui
vient et revient qui est la question de
fessenheim et en particulier le fait que
ce plan le plan de démantèlement de
fessenheim prévoit de recycler les
générateurs de vapeur de la centrale
principe appliqué dans des pays comme
l'allemagne et la suède mais pas en
france est ce qu'on peut faire le point
sur les évolutions techniques et
réglementaires en cours pour permettre
ce recyclage dans les conditions de
sûreté maîtrisé est ce qu'il ya des
difficultés particulières ou est ce que
c'est une opération qui il faut
envisager avec une relative sérénité une
question sur les ressources humaines
alors c'est quelque chose qui s'est
invité beaucoup d'auditions et vous avez
insisté là dessus aussi avec la demande
à l'état à l'opérateur edf de de
spécifier de rendre compte annuellement
de la capacité à faire comme vous le
disiez à faire avec les avec les
ressources humaines sur le sur les
ressources humaines
premièrement dans votre éditorial
monsieur le directeur général vous avez
souligné la complexité croissante des
questions à traiter qui va nécessiter de
recruter des personnels expérimentés ou
disposant de compétences rares cela
malgré un contexte où on a eu
l'impression globalement d'une certaine
de notre relative désaffection pour
certains des certains des métiers une
relative difficulté à trouver les
personnels dans la filière l'asn à ce
jour recrutent plutôt des ingénieurs
généralistes issus des grands corps de
l'état
est ce que pourrait donner des exemples
de sujets qui justifie cette évolution
des besoins de lui dire pourquoi ça
devient plus plus complexes et comment
est ce que vous envisagez à venir par
rapport à cela en clair est ce que il ya
besoin d'une action spécifique des
pouvoirs publics ou de quelque chose
d'un plan qui permettent de favoriser
l'émergence de tels profils les
ressources humaines ça c'est pour la
question des profils spécialisés
un autre une autre question qui s'est
invitée dans qui s'invitent
régulièrement et qui s'est invité encore
récemment c'est celle de la celle de la
sous traitance et le est ce qu'on peut
dire c'est un sujet sur lequel nous
avions déjà alerté en fin et on fait le
relais de préoccupations des acteurs du
nucléaire dès 2011 dans la mission
post-fukushima de l'opex nécessité de
gérer de façon plus sur les conditions
de la sous traitance vous signaler dans
votre rapport une augmentation très
importante des travaux sur les centrales
nucléaires
on sait que la question est sous
traitance et délicate il ya encore eu
récemment des alertes sur des fraudes
dans le cas de sous traitance qui ne
semble pas avoir eu de qui ne semble pas
avoir eu de conséquences
particulièrement inquiétante mais pour
nous faire un point sur ces questions de
la sûreté dans le domaine de la
sous-traitance question suivante celle
de la recherche à salissant des
recherches liées à la sûreté nucléaire
est ce que les moyens disponibles
aujourd'hui vous semble à la hauteur des
enjeux
est ce qu'il ya des risques
éventuellement anticiper sur l'expertisé
le contrôle
quelle est votre politique quels sont
vos recommandations en matière de
crédits de recherche et quels organismes
de recherche à utile de mobiliser en
france ou à l'étranger
dans ce cadre une dernière question les
organisations non gouvernementale
greenpeace et négawatt ont récemment
publié un rapport estimant que dix ans
après fukushima pour les centrales
nucléaires d'edf
seuls 12 des 23 mesures
structurantes identifié après fukushima
ont été mises en place sur l'ensemble du
parc
est ce que vous partagez ce constat
alarmiste faut-il le nuancer et à quelle
échéance
estimez-vous que l'ensemble des mesures
post fukushima pourront être appliquées
voilà pour mes questions la sénatrice
angèle préville a levé la main et je
vous propose de découper également sa ou
ses questions avant de passer à vos
réponses monsieur le directeur général
monsieur le président merci monsieur le
président donc merci pour votre
présentation
comme beaucoup de questions ont déjà été
posées je voulais juste parce que j'ai
des interrogations à ce sujet sur les
cuves
donc vous avez parlé les cuves en acier
sur l'exposition aux rayonnements et
notamment sur le fait qu'il y ait des
problèmes anciens de problèmes à venir
sur le prolongement sur les 32 réacteurs
c'est qu elles ont été fabriquées sur le
même modèle
est ce que vous savez combien de deux
cuves seraient concernés exactement
parce cette problématique là et après
moi j'ai toujours une question par
rapport aux enceintes de confinement qui
sont en béton
le béton devenant poreux au cours du
temps est ce que il ya aussi une
vigilance à ce sujet là et après sur sur
un autre sujet sur la gestion des
matières et des déchets radioactifs
je m'interroge parce que sur le bilan
vous nous avez donné dans votre
présentation sur la faible activité
saturation des stocks vous me direz si
j'ai bien noté sur les faibles activités
vie longue
aucune solution apparemment sur les
graphiques et les bitumes et et sur le
projet cigéo des risques pour l'instant
et puis un projet qui n'est pas encore
effectif donc finalement si on regarde
sur tous ces déchets on pourrait presque
conclure qu'on a qu'on est face à une
situation de
des solutions qui ne sont qui ne sont
pas là et est même sûr si on se projette
un petit peu sur l'absence de solution
dans un avenir proche et voir à moyen
terme
donc voilà je voulais vous interrogé à
ce sujet là parce que je trouve ça
plutôt inquiétant voilà merci beaucoup
merci chers collègues
en fait il ya une encore une autre
question de la députée ml carew qui a un
petit regret sur une question que là où
mise
oui alors c'est pour parler plus
spécifiquement du sujet de la faille de
sécurité sur la centrale de flamanville
vous savez que il a été médiatisé que
des documents de sécurité du site
avaient avaient été rendues publiques et
qui a été rendue publique l'intégralité
des documents de sécurité avec vidéo
protection etc
toutes les données ont été rendues
publiques et donc avec la députée matic
panneaux nous avons proposé une
résolution pour demander une commission
denquête donc ça ça va ça va avancer
mais est ce que vous pourriez nous dire
ce que vous pensez de cette faille de
sécurité
merci chers collègues monsieur le
président monsieur le directeur général
à vous la parole
monsieur le président une amie je
voulais juste vous faire part d'une
petite difficulté technique que nous
rencontrons parce que en fait bernard
derosier que ces faits déconnecté de 2
voilà de la réunion je ne sais pas
exactement quand est ce que la ville
j'ai prise j'ai pris un certain nombre
de questions mais voilà donc à se mettre
à côté de moi on va changer un tout
petit peu position arrivait à répondre
ensemble à vos questions navteq s'il ya
besoin nous le répéterons ce n'est pas
un problème mais prenons tout le temps
qu'il faut pour aplanir l'ensemble de
l'ensemble des questions
nous ne nous entendons pas vous
m'entendez oui on va regarder
est-ce que vous m'entendez oui
maintenant nous entendons très bien donc
je vais effectivement répondre avec
olivier puisque je n'ai pas pu capter un
certain nombre de questions ayant il y
aurait été coupée à peu près au milieu
de vos interventions
donc je vais démarrer par celle que j'ai
entendu et notamment je vais commencer
par le sujet des smr est notamment
l'opportunité que pourrait présenter ces
petits réacteur modulaire dans le cadre
des réflexions qui sont en cours sur la
politique énergétique en france donc
comme ça a été dit c'est un le sujet des
smr est un sujet qui suscite un intérêt
un fort intérêt est de fort soutien à
l'innovation notamment dans les pays
anglo saxons il ya aujourd'hui à peu
près 70 projets de smr qui sont recensés
dans le monde et il ya quelques
éphémères qui sont déjà en exploitation
il ya une barge flottante enfin en
russie où des éphémères qui sont dans un
stade avancé de conception notamment aux
états unis en chine et en corée du sud
oui oui on vous entend bien le pardon je
voulais juste l'interrompt pour préciser
quand vous dites 70 projets il s'agit de
70 modèles différents et ses 210
construction se répartissant selon
différents modèles
non ce sont des projets qui seront
encore les projets papier des projets
papier qui correspondent à des
conceptions très différentes
ça peut être des micros smr de très très
peu faible puissance 1 mégawatt par
exemple ou des réacteurs de alors
jusqu'à 300 mégawatts la large et la
came très large de 1 à 300 mégawatts
donc 70 projets papier correspondant à
des conceptions très différentes ça
peut-être des smr à eau sous pression
c'est le projet français par exemple où
le projet américain
peut-être des dlc mer à celle front du
dsm héros plots dsm est rousse sodium
donc il ya vraiment un foisonnement de
concept extrêmement large et dans le
monde
on en ressent sur un dock fait 70
projets il y en a très peu qui sont à un
stade avancé
il y en a notamment aux etats-unis et en
chine
mais c'est très très peu ça se compte
sur les doigts d'une main et puis il ya
un seul à ma connaissance un seul essai
nero d'exploitation qui est une barge
flottante en russie voilà alors il ya il
ya un premier essai mère d'une puissance
de 120 mégawatts a été homologué par nos
homologues américains et des canadiens
etc
c'est un smr qui pourrait entrer en
service en 2029
loria un consortium français constitué
de d'edf du cera de techniques at home
et de nova groupe qui travaille sur un
projet smr d'une puissance de 170
mégawatts et ce consortium vise
essentiellement à ce stade un marché à
l'étranger
un marché de remplacement et centrales
au charbon ou des centrales au gaz
notamment mais dans le cadre de ce
projet ce consortium envisage de mettre
en place en france un démonstrateur qui
permettrait de valider les concepts donc
par rapport à la question directe qui
était posé sur finalement la sûreté de
ces sms représente il a des avantages
significatifs en matière de sûreté
alors c'est effectivement le cas en tout
cas au vu des discussions que nous avons
avec nos homologues et au niveau
international alors vous n'étiez pas
parler des discussions au niveau de oued
rats c'est ces petits réacteurs goodyear
présente tout d'abord une une capacité
de sécurité ou de sûreté passive
c'est-à-dire que en cas d'accident il
n'y a pas besoin d'intervention humaine
et il n'y a pas besoin de source
d'énergie externe dont pouvoir maintenir
le niveau de sûreté de ces réacteurs
donc une sécurité intrinsèque et passive
de ses réacteurs en situation
accidentelle
ensuite ce sont des réacteurs de moindre
puissance de petite puissance dont la
puissance à évacuer en cas d'accident
est bien évident plus plus faible et
dans le projet français
le projet français est un projet qui
pourrait conduire un petit réacteur
fonctionnerait sans bord le bord est un
poison qui est utilisé dans la conduite
des directeurs mais surtout en situation
accidentelle pour réduire les effets de
radioactivité et les effets de
l'emballement du réacteur en cas
d'accident le fait qu'il n'y ait pas de
bord c'est ça conduit à éviter les
accidents de dilution parce que c'est un
petit accident qui peut exister et sa
limite bien évident la production
d'effluents puisque le bord est aussi
utilisé pour pouvoir faire fonctionner
en situation normale le reste donc tout
ceci la situe pas été facile une résine
puissance résiduelle moindre à évacuer
un fonctionnement sans d'or tout ceci
pourrait constituer des désavantages des
avantages significatifs à considérer en
cas de nouveau nucléaire surtout pour
des périodes longues de 60 à 80 ans
parce que ce sont ces smr pourrait
présenter les avantages de ne pas être
exposés au risque de rejet en cas
d'accident donc ça c'est un point
fondamental de ces réacteurs
modulaire et de petite taille mais il ya
encore beaucoup d'étapes à franchir
tout ça c'est un peu de la théorie un
peu des papiers les projets ne sont
encore au stade des études
donc il ya encore de nombreuses
hypothèses de conception qui restent à
valider il ya un certain nombre de
verrous technologiques qui sont encore à
lever et il faudra vraisemblablement des
outils de calcul spécifique peut-être
des maquettes certainement des maquettes
représentative pour pouvoir valider les
différentes options il faut rester
prudent et uniquement sur le papier ça
paraît très très intéressant si c'est
avéré c'est certainement une option
il faut mettre sur la table dans une
réflexion à moyen terme sur le nucléaire
compte tenu de l'avantagé de l'absence
de risque de rejet en cas d'accident
mais ça il ya encore beaucoup de travail
à faire
dernier avantage ou désavantage du
projet français à la fin des mrc que
leur conception pourrait être tel que
c'est ces réacteurs soient enterrées ou
semi-enterrées ce qui confère à la
allard
l'inspiration une robuste est supérieure
contre les risques d'agression et
notamment la chute d'avion et dans tout
ce qui a trait aux risques notamment de
risque d'attentât ou autres sécurité en
fait du réacteur voilà en ce qui
concerne les avantages de céret et
pardon monsieur le président également
je crois que ça avait été évoqué dans
une autre audition peut-être vous pouvez
confirmer au niveau de la conception il
ya une standardisation plus importante
n'est ce pas dans les dents les petits
réacteurs modulaire qui simplifie
l'évaluation le chantier est
potentiellement les délais le la
construction la mise en oeuvre n'est ce
pas donc c'est ce petit réacteur
pourrait être essentiellement fabriquées
en usine
donc ça effectivement en termes de
maîtrise des conditions de construction
se serait vraisemblablement un avantage
la fabrication serait aussi simple les
facteurs peuvent être également associés
ils sont modulaires et donc on peut les
assembler un peu comme des lego pour
pouvoir augmenter la puissance
d'ensemble donc c'est aussi un élément
qui pourrait être favorable
en revanche ce sont des réacteurs qui
représente un coût assez assez important
et une seule des déchets de grande série
pourrait permettre de fournir des
réacteurs
un coût compétitif mais tendre
produisant de l'électricité à un coût
compétitif
donc il ya quand même beaucoup encore de
sujet à lever mais il ya à l'évidence
des avantages en termes
d'industrialisation et en termes de
sûreté
alors peut-être en vient à la question
qui a été posée à plusieurs faits sur la
sur les cuves de réacteurs pour appeler
ce que nous avons été amenés à faire
dans le cadre de l'instruction du
dossier de réexamen périodique des
quatre des dix réacteurs de 900
mégawatts d'edf est la meilleure pour
nous avons traité le sujet des tirs au
filet tout à fait clair que et je l ai
dit dans mon intervention que la tenue
dès qu il est un élément déterminant
pour la durée de vie des réacteurs
parce que le métal des cuves êtes
exposés aux rayonnements et les
caractéristiques mécaniques de ce métal
s'affaiblissent au fil du temps du fait
de ce rayonnement à l'origine de la
construction des réacteurs de 900
mégawatts
la durée de vie qui avait été envisagé
et et d'autres 40 ans et donc les études
de conception réalisé à ce moment là
était avec une vérification de la tenue
d'études pour 40 ans c'est pour ça que
le réexamen de sûreté des réacteurs de
900 mégawatts pour aller au tas de 40
ans et est un sujet sensible donc bien
évidemment l'edf a fourni un certain
nombre de justification ci ont été
analysés par l'irsn donc étaient
analysées par le groupe d'experts
permanent de la sl et ses justifications
nous avons semblé probante pour pouvoir
accepter le relogement entre 40 et 50
ans certaines de ces cuves des réacteurs
de 900 mégawatts à qui doit y en avoir à
peu près une dizaine sont aussi des
cuves qui sont affectés de défauts
d'origine c'est-à-dire au moment où il
ya eu à la fabrication des textures il
ya eu quelques micro fissures qui ont
été détectés ils sont suivis en
permanence et qu'ils n'ont pas évolué
depuis la fabrication initial donc
l'ensemble de ces éléments le contrôle
de l'état réel des cubes notamment celle
de tricastin 1
les études réalisées par edf ont été
analysés et nous ont conduit à estimer
qu'il était envisageable que c'est qu'il
était possible de prolonger la durée de
fonctionnement des réacteurs de 900
mégawatts pour dix ans supplémentaires
est ce que je disais dans mon propos
liminaire c'est que les éléments qu'ils
ont été fournies ne vont que chose 15 50
ans donc nous n'avons pour l'instant pas
d'élément permettant de
nous positionner au delà de 50 ans il
faudra vraisemblablement pour certains
une cuve edf face des analyses
complémentaires des justifications
complémentaires
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai dit
qu'il fallait que nous anticipions le
plus vite possible ces analyses pour
pouvoir se poser la question de la
possibilité d'aller au delà de 50 ans
voire de 60 ans suffisamment tôt pour
que le gouvernement les opérateurs
puissent prendre les décisions qui
s'imposent au cas où il ne pourrait pas
être justifié d'une tenue de ces cubes
au delà de 50 ans et jusqu'à 50 ans les
analyses que nous avons faites jusqu'à
présent nous permettent de dire que
c'est possible
merci bien continuons ce alors je
continue sur le png mdr donc c'est tout
à fait vrai que la durée du plan et a
été prolongée futur plan de 3 à 5 ans si
c'est vrai qu'il y a qu il y a un retard
par rapport à l'échéance normale
d'élaboration du cinquième pngmdr le
plan est élaboré par le ministère de la
transition écologique et la snd
participe bien évidemment à
l'élaboration de ce plan mais non on
n'en est plus le maître ouvrage nous et
plus le omettre noura alors le retard
qui a été observée peut s'expliquer
parce que pour la première fois le plan
la préparation du plan a fait l'objet
d'un débat public
le débat public a été important bien il
en est arrivé là il s'est étalé sur
quasiment une année avec ses conclusions
et au vu des conclusions du débat public
le ministère de la transition écologique
à souhaiter de plus mettre en place une
une commission une commission dite
d'orientation qui rassemble les
différentes parties concernées pour
exploiter non seulement les conclusions
du débat public mais aussi exploiter les
avis émis par l'asn pour proposer à au
ministère de la transition écologique et
les éléments les plus
stratégiques et les plus importants en
termes d'orientation à mettre en place
d'un plan donc il ya eu un processus qui
est très différent de l'élaboration des
plans précédents qui peut me semble t-il
expliqué le retard en revanche les
enjeux sont considérables de notre point
de vue est fait ce que j'ai indiqué tout
à l'heure et escape est l'objet jours ci
d'une question c'est le fait que
l'ensemble des filières de gestion
lorsqu'on les prend une à une sont des
filières de gestion pour lesquels
beaucoup de travaux d'analysé préalables
ont été faits pour la recherche de
solutions mais pour lesquels aucune
décision n'a été prise
je prendrai l'exemple des déchets très
faiblement radioactifs qui permettra de
répondre à la dernière question que
j'avais entendu il est fait le monsieur
le président de la valorisation des
déchets tfa métallique liés au projet de
démantèlement de la centrale de
fessenheim
donc on a on a aujourd'hui un stockage
pour ces déchets très faiblement
radioactifs et de capacités line hi tech
et les six ans où 650 mille mètres cubes
et il pourrait éventuellement moyennant
quelques aménagements être augmenté
jusqu'à 900 mille mètres cubes en
revanche que l'estimation du volume de
déchets tfa aspect au chenal et le
minimum de 2 millions 3 donc il y à deux
mètres cubes donc il ya bien évidemment
un écart considérable et la saturation
des capacités de stockage des déchets
tf1 pourrait apparaître d'ici 2028 ou
2035 selon l'option qui retenu qu'il
faut bien évidemment anticipées se
trouver un nouveau site centralisé
c'est extrêmement la demande du temps
d'abord il faut concevoir ce ce nouveau
projet s'est trouvé un cercueil
donc il faut anticiper pour pouvoir
avoir à partir de 2030 2035 une solution
de continuité cette décision il faut la
prendre dans les cinq ans teaser il y
aura aucune chance d'avoir une capacité
de stockage disponible à horizon 2035
tirs d'autres options permettent de
réduire le volume des déchets sont à
stocker une finale bien dix ans ce sont
des solutions qu'il faut étudier mettre
en oeuvre une de ces solutions
et celui de réduire le volume de déchets
ffa ou stockées en valorisant les
déchets métalliques en volume
quasiment les plus importants quand on
additionne à la fois des et les
terrienne des installations d'eau rano
des équipements métalliques des
installations de panneaux de bf savent
c'est effectivement un volume tout à
fait important donc valoriser ses
déchets tf1 ça permet de réduire le
volume des déchets à stocker une finale
ça c'est important
donc il ya un pardon monsieur le
président pouvez vous être explicite sur
ce qu'on entend par valoriser dans ce
contexte alors justement il ya eu
effectivement une partie du débat qui a
été publique un cas porté sur cette
capacité de valorisation et nous avons
asn et des ministères de la transition
écologique définit une orientation qui
consisteraient à permettre la
valorisation des déchets métalliques
dans le cadre d'un proche dans le
process industriel dans une installation
centralisée unique
il serait une installation veut de
refusions dans laquelle l'ensemble des
déchets métalliques tf1 serait
effectivement refondu ce qui permettrait
d'ailleurs de d'éliminer en séparant une
part des produits frais une part de
radioactivité substantielle et d'avoir
une chine est un produit final un
produit après refusions métalliques dans
le niveau de radioactivité serait
extrêmement faible un problème et
surtout il serait en dessous des seuils
de libération sont définies au niveau
communautaire et qui sont extrêmement
elles ont réduit le seuil de libération
pour eux c'est ce qu'ils se donnent là
des chiffres et de 10 microsieverts par
an aux points à l'issue du processus
industriels les déchets deviendraient
des produits valorisables dont le niveau
de radioactivité serait inférieur à 10
microsieverts par an et micro sievert
par an c'est parfois moins que
l'exposition annuelle de la population
française aux rayons cosmiques par
exemple donc ce sont des valeurs qui
sont extrêmement faibles
bien plus faible que l'exposition
naturelle de la population au club ce
projet nous semble possible possible
parce qu'il est industriellement
contrôlable dans des installations dans
des installations on peut faire des
contrôles des produits à l'entrée on
peut faire un contrôle lors de la mise
en place du processus de fusion
et on peut faire bien sûr un contrôle
pièce par pièce des produits qui sortent
de cette visite qui est pas du tout le
cas pour les autres déchets tf1 l'autre
grand volume de déchets tfa ce sont les
gravats à paris
il est pas du tout possible d'envisager
à ce stade un processus industriel à qui
permettrait d'avoir autant de garanties
en matière de contrôle donc la position
de l'asn
en ce qui concerne ses cd chez tf1 ça
reste une position que nous avons
exprimé à l'occasion de notre avis en
2020 qui est de dire nous ne sommes pas
favorables à la mise en place de seuil
de libération généralisée lorsque ce
sont des opérations qui sont complexes à
réaliser en termes de contrôle est
passablement acceptable en revanche nous
pensons que de manière ciblée pour ce
qui concerne les déchets métalliques
parce que l'on ferait appel un processus
industriels puissent être peut être mis
sous contrôle
la sape les enjeux on va la perdre et ça
réduire de manière substantielle le
volume final de déchets tfa à stocker
mais ces décisions il faut les prendre
pour l'instant elles ne sont pas prises
il faut les prendre
[Musique]
merci bien
on a bien compris comment j'y tiens
beaucoup d' analyse beaucoup de
propositions beaucoup d'identification
de problèmes et d'obstacles un moment il
faut choisir et ça je peux être chose
une décision qui doit être prise dans
l'adhésion qui doivent être prises dans
les cinq années à venir sinon on va se
retrouver à la fin de la décennie qui
commence maintenant face à une
saturation des capacités de stockage
continuons si cela vous convient
monsieur le président
je vous demande simplement 30 secondes
tu es changer de bureau puisque la ligne
a été rétablie à plus confortable pour
intervenir allez-y vous en prie
nous vous voyons monsieur le président
mais nous ne nous entendons pas encore
est-ce que vous m'entendez oui cinq sur
cinq comme parfait a fait merci beaucoup
alors je poursuis bien par rapport aux
questions que j'avais enregistrée il ya
eu une série de questions concernant le
p r et donc je vais faire un croix
peut-être de la situation dont le père
est effectivement un projet qui reste
complexe qui avait subi de très
nombreuses années et ces deux dernières
années ça a été souligné un certain
nombre d'étapes auront été franchies par
exemple ou un décès qui est extrêmement
complet il ya plus d'un millier décès
ces deux performances du réacteur à la
fois en situation normale de
fonctionnement situation occidental a
été déroulé et les résultats de ces
essais sont globalement satisfaisants il
ya un certain nombre d'écarts un certain
nombre de non-conformités ils mériteront
des modifications sur l'installation
avant la mise en service ou juste après
la mise en service et la réalisation de
deux nouveaux essais de validation
on nous avons autorisé en octobre 2020
la livraison l'arrivée du combustible
neuf qui n'ont que le nom du radier sur
flamanville et se conduit cible être
entreposées dans les piscines du
réacteur
où est le retour d'expérience qui a été
cité effectivement de finlande et de
chine soit sur leurs réacteurs en
exploitation de baishan sur le réacteur
qui est encore en fin de vie étant en
phase de mise en service à table de mise
en service qui est en finlande et il y a
un retour d'expérience a exploité par
edf
notamment il ya eu la découverte de
corrosion sous contrainte sur les
pilotes et les tiges des soupapes cirque
les maires donc ça ne mérite à des
modifications de ses pilotes
edf travaille sur ce sujet et puis en
chine après la mise en service des
réacteurs de taishan
il ya un certain nombre d'anomalies qui
ont été détectés sur la distribution de
puissance du coeur des réacteurs et là
encore ça nécessite des investigations
et des modifications
de la part d'edf au contraire une
vigilance particulière d'edf au moment
de la mise en service est là le père de
flamanville donc hormis les soudures
voyez vous il ya quand même de nombreux
sujets qui sont encore ouverts sur
lesquelles l'asm ne disposent pas
toujours de l'ensemble des éléments de
la part d'edf ou pour les instruire et
donc pour trancher
et donc il ya quand même une certaine
urgence à ce que edf termine ses
analyses sur tous ces sujets et en
transmette les conclusions à la scène
6-6 notamment si edf veut tenir son
objectif d'une mise en service vers 2020
et le sujet le plus important ce sont
les soudures donc il ya une centaine de
soudure du circuit tapper principal ils
sont concernés par par des écarts l'edf
l'a prévu d'en réparer certaines de
maintenir en l'état
après justification d'autres les
procédés d'âge ont été définis ils ont
fait l'objet d'essais spécifiques et
nous les avons nous avons plus de tf1
les réparations sont réalisés par l'eau
à ce stade aujourd'hui il ya sur l'a13
soudure sur une cinquantaine du circuit
vapeur et ont fait l'objet d'un feu vert
de la place de la part de la scène et y
en a sept sur 13 ont été réparés
entièrement et toute manière tout à fait
satisfaisant ce qu'ils disent qu'ils
montrent que est tout à fait possible
lorsque les procédés de soudage et les
soudeurs sont qualifiés et ce qui est
évidemment une exigence minimes à la mi
mars l'asn a émis d'objection au
démarrage de la réparation des huit
soudure qui sont les soudures de
traverser enceinte du circuit vapeur ce
sont les plus difficiles sont les
soudures qui devront être réparées avec
un robot donc nous avons donné notre
accord de feu vert pour que la
réparation soient réalisés bien
évidemment ça veut dire que nous n'avons
pas d'objection par rapport aux
propositions qui sont faites par edf
mais c'est bien l'une en haut des airs
qui ont la responsabilité du choix de la
méthode de réparation qui est mise en
jeu
pardon monsieur le président pascal
effectivement ça un point majeur et un
peu spectaculaire comment juste en
quelques mots que qui fabrique le robot
comment est il que quelques y at il des
choses important de savoir sur sa sur sa
réalisation
alors le robot à être a été un robot
qualifiés qui avait déjà fait l'objet
d'une mise en oeuvre par westinghouse à
l'étranger en france à une telle
opération de réparation par l'intérieur
des soudures n'avait jamais été réalisé
avec un mot donc là le robot a été
qualifiée pour la dimension des des
tuyauteries et des soudures à réaliser
il y a eu des opérations qui ont
consisté à enlever une partie une
manchette 1 sur le circuit secondaire de
manière à pouvoir faire rentrer le robot
et aime d'ailleurs faire entrer un
soudeur parce que il a fallu faire une
passe rasim s'adonnent pas accostage à
la main et le robot ne pouvait pas faire
cette passe d'accostage par lui-même
donc un soudeur qui pour donner un
exemple de la complexité ce soudeur et
est entré dans la tuyauterie mhz avec
une combinaison réfrigéré est ce que le
loonie température à l'intérieur de
l'organisation étaient 250 degrés donc
il a fallu faire entrer une personne
dans des conditions assez spécial tout
ceci a été a été chef pour une première
soudure et de manière satisfaisante donc
la machine d'europe de soulages
automatique maintenant est en place et
réalise les premières soudure se suivant
les procédés qui ont été qualifiés et
mise en oeuvre par westinghouse
il ya eu un très long processus de
validation et d'entraînement de
validation du procédé de soudage
d'entraînement des shooteurs de
vérification des paramètres qui est
maintenant démarrer sur les huit soudure
de traverser ans
c'est la partie la plus complexe de la
réparation mais il ya comme je l'aï dit
il ya quand même une cinquantaine de
soudure du circuit secondaire réparer
et il ya une trentaine du circuit d'eau
vapeur ou dollars dont l'alimentation
qui sont haussières et parce qu'il ya
quand même 80 sous mur alors globalement
peu près 80 ce mur qui sont à peu près
aussi tout se passe bien
ces opérations de réparation vont se
poursuivre et elles vont se poursuivre
jusqu'au début de 2022 et ses soudures
sont clairement sur le chemin critique
du projet il ya plus de marge par
rapport à l objectif car edf d'obtenir
une autorisation de mise en service pour
fin 2022
la réparation de ses soudures et sur le
chemin qui est plus récemment nous avons
été informés en mars d'une nouvelle non
conformité en matière de soudage qui ne
concerne pas les soudures du circuit
secondaire mais qui concerne les sorties
certaines soudures de piquage qui sont
présentes sur le circuit primaire
principal donc le circuit en eau sous
pression qui est en contact direct avec
le coeur du réacteur et il manque deux
générateurs de vapeur c'est ses soudures
y en a trois n'ont pas été réalisées
conformément à ce qui était prévu à la
conception elles ont une dimension aux
plus grandes et cette dimension est
telle que des monstres et ne sont pas
couverts la rupture de ces canalisations
pardon n'est pas couverte n'est pas
prise en compte par la démonstration de
sûreté
il y avait été réalisé à l'initial dès
qu'il postulait dépiquage deux
dimensions - donc il ya un sujet pour
ces trois piquage et c'est soudure de
piquage après vérification ne
remplissent pas la totalité des critères
qui sont exigés pour pouvoir bénéficier
de la fameuse clause d'exclusion rupture
c'est à dire la qualité des soudures et
pas tel que l'on puisse postuler
kaehlin de ce est très faible proportion
très faible probabilité pardon pour que
et donc on ne peut pas exclure la
rupture de ses soudures et donc il faut
soit bien évidemment les consolider ou
réparés donc le travail la reine va
s'effectuer edf est en train de
réfléchir sur les stratégies possibles
pour pouvoir remettre en état
l'installation il ya trois options qui
sont étudiées par edf sur ces trois
piquage primaire il ya une option qui
consiste à consolider le piquage en
mettent en place des écoliers de matin
qui serait démontable et qui permettrait
donc limiter les conséquences
éventuelles ruptures de ces suture ça
c'est la première option est la deuxième
option c'est ben c'est de couper et de
remplacer les tronçons qui comporte
cevital et la troisième option c'est de
réparer les soudures pour pouvoir le rpt
et les faire bénéficier de la démarche
d'exclusion ayant cessé trois options
change pour pas du tout le même impact
sur le projet seule l'option 1
permettrait d'espérer de rester dans le
calendrier visé par edf pour une mise en
service de le père avant fin 2020 deux
donc c'est cette option qui est
privilégiée par edf etc et nous
prendrons position sur la faisabilité de
cette option un durant l'été voilà ce
que je voulais dire monsieur le
président sur le p r merci beaucoup pour
ces pour ces précisions
continuons si vous le voulez bien alors
je parlais du plain jane des airs de sa
dure l alerte sur les cubes je pense en
avoir en a parlé
en ce qui concerne les les
la politique énergétique d'une certaine
manière qui est envisagée en france et
le
le besoin de marge pour la sûreté donc
je confirme bien évidemment c'est
l'exposition à ces anciens de l'essai
n'a que analyse un il ressort clairement
qu'il faut maintenir des marges ans qui
compte sur le système électrique pour
pouvoir faire face à des riches qui en
termes de sûreté
on l'a vu par le passé on ne peut pas
exclure un aléa qui ne conduirait à
prendre une décision pour des raisons de
sûreté d'arrêt un ou par de plusieurs
réacteurs et face à une telle situation
il faut que le système électrique
dispose de marche notamment pour faire
face aux situations hivernale où sont
les plus tendues l'interconnexion
internationaux des réseaux peut bien
évidemment être utilisé pour pouvoir
compléter les marges française mais dès
lors que ces interconnexions sont aussi
capables
pendant la même période d'être valorisé
bon exemple qui est souvent cité ces si
ces interconnexions permettent
d'alimenter le réseau électrique
national
du fait de la production électrique
parfois d'éoliennes à l'étranger il n'y
a pas de vent c'est la connexion de ne
sont pas opérante et ne donne pas de
trucs donc il faut rester prudent et
c'est un peu mince le deuxième message
c'est celui dont seulement il faut des
marges mais il faut rester prudent parce
que on ne peut pas on ne peut pas
garantir que en situation de risque pour
le réseau électrique
on pourrait bénéficier en france de deux
soutiens de production étrangers alors
il ya des dispositifs qui existent pour
pouvoir alléger la demande en
électricité sur le réseau le verre peut
mettre en place en tant que régulateur
non c'est la coupure qui peuvent être
organisés donc ces éléments doivent être
pris en compte pour pouvoir faire face à
une situation tendue sur le réseau
électrique
parce que ce qu'il ne faudrait pas c'est
ça notre population sait que
la situation tendue en matière de
réseaux électriques influence
conditionne des décisions de sûreté que
nous aurions à prendre de sûreté
nucléaire pour cela il faut qu'il y ait
des marges pour la sûreté de telle
manière à ce qu'il n'y ait pas de n'ai
pas de doute sur notre capacité à agir
pour ce qui concerne le plus long terme
ce que nous disons c'est que non
seulement il faut des marges mais tout
le long terme il faut aussi anticiper
parce que c'est finalement des centrales
nucléaires dont on pas éternel
un moment donné elles devront être mises
à l'arrêt et si les projections qui sont
aujourd'hui fait dans le cadre de la
prochaine tpe sont des projections qui
postule la possibilité de d'avoir à
disposition des capacités de production
électrique par exemple renouvelables
suffisante
aussi les marges dégagées par les
politiques d'efficacité énergétique
permettent effectivement l'arrêt des
réacteurs
au bout d'un certain temps si ses
perspectives et ses projections n'était
pas au rendez vous il ne faudrait pas
que la conséquence en soit le souhait de
prolonger le le fonctionnement des
réacteurs nucléaires c'est pour ça que
je dis il faut absolument anticiper pour
qu'on sache par rapport à la
problématique des cuves ont été cités
tout à l'heure pour lesquels nous
n'avons pas de garantie à ce stade au
delà des 50 ans
il faut anticiper et recherche il faut
anticiper le débat sur ce sujet pour
être pour savoir exactement ce qu'il en
sera et les prendre des décisions en
conséquence monsieur le président par
rapport à votre importante importante
remarque que vous venez de faire je me
permets de revenir sur cette question
dès qu au delà de 50 ans sk des éléments
des éléments particuliers qui qui
appelle à la vigilance sur une durée
particulière et ce qui est des
caractéristiques physiques et pourquoi
est ce que c'est que finalement il ya
une
une une vigilance particulière au delà
de 50 ans que vous évoquez alors là
caractéristiques mécaniques qui
s'affaiblit et à travers le temps c'est
l'affluence du matériau dont kylie a
effectivement si cette dégradation est
importante
il y a il peut y avoir un risque pour la
tenue des cubes alors il ya plusieurs
parades pour pouvoir éviter la
dégradation du ou métal de la cub s'est
par exemple d'avoir une gestion
combustible la répartition finalement du
combustible à l'intérieur du coeur qui
soient adaptés et qu'ils fassent en
sorte que le métal notamment qui est le
plus proche et des crayons combustible
qui sont périphérie soit moins affectés
par le rayonnement
donc il ya des mesures de gestion qui
sont possibles pour réduire l'exposition
du métal de la cub à travers le temps
voyez vous c'est une possibilité
il ya bien évidemment aussi des
réflexions à mener sur les traitements
éventuels peuvent être faits sur le
matériau lui-même au pouvoir en
améliorer les caractéristiques
mécaniques
c'est envisageable ça se fait d'après ce
que je crois savoir à l'étranger avant a
dû se faire aux états unis donc voilà ce
sont des sujets que nous n'avons pas
exploré en france mais qu'il faut
absolument explorer pour savoir s'il ya
des parades qui pourraient être mises en
oeuvre pour aller bien au delà des 50
ans que le répète pour les 50 ans les
analyses que nous avons obtenu des
experts qui se sont prononcés sur les
résultats de ces analyses sont claires
jusqu'à 50 ans les cuves des réacteurs
de 900 mégawatts y compris les cumuls
seront donc les deux défauts d'origine
de son jeu sont pas en cause il n'y a
pas de risque pour la sûreté c'est pour
ça que nous avons pris date est la
décision génériques
sinon nous l'aurions tellement appris
mais les résultats qui me sont données
montrent que ce n'est pas ce n'est pas
garanti pour aller au delà de 50 ans
alors bien évidemment ce n'est pas
garanti pour les réacteurs ça peut aussi
il faut il ne faut pas le nepg dès lors
que les analyses sont poussés au
au bout ça pourrait conduire de dh à
choisir les réacteurs qui doivent faire
l'objet
tel que prévu actuellement par la ppe
d'ici 2035 puisqu'il ya douze réacteurs
en plus des deux réacteurs qui ont été
arrêtés le fesman y ait de la tpe
doivent être arrêtés entre 2028 et 2035
donc ce que ce qui me paraît absolument
indispensable de faire c'est de prendre
en compte des sujets de sûreté notamment
celui qu'on vient d'évoquer sur les
risques dits la cub pour finalement
articulé l'arrêt des réacteurs de 900
mégawatts au titre de la ppe avec
l'échéance dès 50 ans c'est tout à fait
possible
il y a entre 2028 pas d'ici 2035 pardon
il ya quinze réacteurs de 900 mégawatts
ils atteindront leurs 50 ans 15 vecteurs
et edf doit choisir 12 réacteurs au
titre de la ppe est donc il conviendrait
que edf intègre les résultats des
analyses en termes de sûreté pour
choisir de manière judicieuse
dix réacteurs arrêtés donc c est tout à
fait possible mais pour ça il faut se
pencher à faux sur le sujet et il se
pensait à fond sur qu'est ce qui se
passe après 50 ans est fondamental il
faut anticiper sur ce quoi je ne sais
pas s'ils vont ils à l'est la snp si
olivier ou d'autres personnes veulent
intervenir ou compléter peut-être pas
parce qu'il ya quand même encore pas mal
de questions qu'il faut pas une traite
et je vois le temps tourne un peu ton
tout le temps tournant parce que vous
avez ce que vous avez évoquées monsieur
le président est très très substantiel
très significatif et des pistes nous
retenons bien sûr votre appel fort à
anticiper pour la suite dans le cadre de
ces opérations prolongement le cas de la
sélection quels sont les centrales dont
il faut envisager l'arrêt et ainsi de
suite
évidemment prise en compte de ces
questions de sûreté dans les décisions
d'edf à venir et quelque chose
d'indispensable
effectivement il reste encore pas mal de
questions continuons nous verrons après
si nous avons un peu de temps pour
revenir sur certains des points d'accord
alors autre question que j'avais
effectivement entendu c'est la question
sur la fusion alors effectivement nous
avons la fusion et les perspectives en
termes de mise en place d'une éventuelle
filière nucléaire du sujet donc ça fait
tout ça référence directement des
ligaments au projet iter le projet iter
qui est un projet de démonstration de
fusion nucléaire par confinement
magnétique avec un plasma confinement
magnétique de deutérium et de tritium
qui seraient amenés à fusionner à
l'intérieur de ce plasma à très très
hautes températures
l'installation militaire est unique au
monde et elle est encore en cours de
construction
le planning prévisionnel de
fonctionnement d'iter est un planning
qui comporte plusieurs phases la
première phase qui pourrait survenir
dans les années à venir c'est un la
réalisation d'un premier plasma il
ferait pas radioactifs et la mise en
place d'un premier plasma est prévue en
et puis bien évidemment il y aura
d'autres étapes ensuite à affranchir et
en 2036 or le planning actuel
iter envisage de faire une première
expérience de fusion thermonucléaire
il ya il ya un planning presque chaîne
le chantier est hors norme et sa mise en
place
demande encore de nombreuses expériences
à réaliser il ya même des certaines
innovations qui restent à valider tout
n'est pas prévu encore il ya encore des
innovations qui font sont en cours au
pouvoir achever la construction du
réacteur iter par exemple il il ya une
recherche en cours sur les nouveaux
matériaux qui permettrait de réduire le
flux n'est trop neutronique à
l'extérieur la réaction de fusion dégage
un flux neutronique considérable et pour
éviter qu'ils se il se propage à
l'extérieur de la cuvée du bâtiment
razer bien évidemment aidé il faut avoir
des écrans et le matériau le choix du
matériau sera fondamental pour réduire
ce flux parce que ce flux conduit bien
évidemment à l'activation il conduit à
désactivation de matériaux à l'excès
ailleurs du réacteur lui-même et puis il
ya un sujet qui est fondamental dans le
fonctionnement du plasma qui est celui
de l'injection du pretium des conditions
d'injection du tritium sont
fondamentales pour faire fonctionner et
maintenir le plasma en état donc voilà
deux sujets de recherche qui ne sont pas
encore achevés et qui sont
indispensables pour faire fonctionner
l'installation iter aussi la
démonstration de fusion par confinement
magnétique et est concluante elle ne
sera donc réalisé que si tout se passe
bien que vers 2036 ensuite dans une
deuxième étape et ça ne sera pas hyper v
y aura une deuxième étape il sera de la
construction d'un pilote la décision et
la construction d'un pilote industriel
de production d'électricité par fusion
et une telle une telle décision et une
telle réalisation ne pourra pas de toute
façon voir le jour avant la seconde
moitié du
de ce siècle
on est dans le démonstrateur et la phase
pilote si tout se passe bien dans le
démonstrateur c'est la deuxième moitié
du siècle dans lequel nous sommes est
lâché la développement d'une filière
alors a fortiori si ensuite le
démonstrateur est probant pour être
envisagée qu'au 22e siècle donc l'homme
la fusion nucléaire est effectivement
peut paraître comme étant un graal mais
il ya encore beaucoup d'étapes à
franchir beaucoup de technologies à
maîtriser ce n'est pas gagné ça ça
permettra effectivement de s'affranchir
de la question de l'approvisionnement en
combustible
la fusion permettant de signer en de le
faire ça permettra de valoriser
d'ailleurs de capacité 1 que nous avons
mais ça ne supprimera pas ça c'est
important ça ne supprimera pas la
question de la gestion des déchets y
aura le problème combustible sera réglé
mais il y aura la gestion de déchets
déchetterie sié qui sont en quantité
très très important et de et de déchets
de produits qui auront été activée dans
l'installation par le flux neutronique
donc ce n'est pas un sujet ce n'est pas
un grave
miracle en termes de la question de la
gestion des déchets monsieur le
président mais grâce à la question de
thomas gaci où nous sommes allés sur
c'est sur ces sujets de recherche de
long terme sur le sur la fusion et c'est
très bien de le remettre en perspective
et elle est dure et que vous évoquez ici
vous parler de projet dans lequel il
s'agit du confinement magnétique mais
commencé il ya aussi une autre une autre
voie confinement inertiel où c'est plus
comme on dit dans laquelle on bombarde
une petite cible de combustible le voile
tenative assez le plasma est ce qu'on
peut dire quelque chose sur le degré
d'avancement de cette autre voie
moi je ne suis pas en mesure de le faire
le seul projet que j'ai à ma
connaissance et je suis allé sur le site
indiquait récemment c'est celui que je
viens d'évoquer
c'est un projet déjà considérable unique
au monde dont je n'ai pas d'information
chant d'autres projets je ne sais pas si
quelqu'un l'asn en disposent
collectivement il faut faire très
attention sur ces sur ces sujets là
parce que quand on parle de deux
concepts un stade extrêmement
préliminaire les choses peuvent
apparaître
daf est séduisante et des problèmes très
concrets notamment en termes de
résistance de matériaux d'ailleurs c'est
un des sujets sur eux sur iter se poser
ensuite quand on va un peu plus loin
dans le détail donc effectivement nous
n'avons à ce stade pas de pas de dossier
d'interaction suffisamment explicite
avec avec d'autres porteurs de projets
de cette nature en oui je pensais au
national ignition facility du du
laboratoire livermore reims avec les
super puissant laser qui sont censés
frappé une toute petite toute petite
bille pour créer pour pour créer les
conditions du plasma de ce que je
comprends c'est une c'est une voie qui
est peut-être encore moins avancé que la
que la voix iter j'avoue mon manque de
connaissances techniques dans le dossier
j'ai visité le national ignition
facility dans le temps j'en sais je n'en
sait guère davantage autre que le fait
que ça correspond à cette autre voie
sept autres approches possibles pour la
fusion à l'échelle industrielle je pense
que le projet iter qui est vraiment un
prochain mondial et certainement le plus
avancé l'échelle industrielle
ok alors quand tu continues ont vraiment
c'est maintenant fait
oui je continue maintenant sur sur les
questions liées à au matières
radioactives à leur valorisation et à la
question qui a été posée sur l'uranium
appauvri
donc effectivement nous avons récemment
toujours dans une approche de précaution
émis un avis en cas de l'est à brasov
plus 5e 20e dr sur les matières nous
avons essayé dans cet avis de définir un
certain nombre de principes qui sont des
principes qui pourraient guider les
pouvoirs publics ce n'est pas la
responsabilité d'al sadd mais c'est la
responsabilité de la dgec et du trésor
trésor des principes en ce qui concerne
le caractère une appréciation de caqueta
valorisables des matières en france on a
bien sûr double régime tant qu'une
matière est considéré comme étant
valorisables elle est désignée que
matière il n'y a pas de besoin de
provisionnement de charge dans cette
matière en revanche si cette matière est
considérée l'honneur elle viendrait
d'une réunion je dis petit pardon
secrétariat petit parasitage avec le
micro de bruno sido merci de régler ça
alors dans la ville dans la ville
dans l'avis de l'asn nous avons nous
avons défini trois étapes à un principe
tout d'abord nous avons dit que on
pouvait raisonnablement estimer qu'une
matière et est valorisable
s'il existait une filière industrielle
d'utilisation de cette matière ou si
elle était réaliste il était réaliste de
la tendance à voir une à horizon de 30
ans et et si la valorisation de ces
matières porté sur des volumes qui sont
cohérents avec les stocks de manière
détenus il en si la valorisation ne
comporte qu'une infime ne permet que de
valoriser qu'une infime partie du stock
ce n'est pas suffisant pour déclarer la
totalité du stock comme étant une
matière valorisable donc première étape
s'il ya une filière réaliste un horizon
de 30 ans on peut considérer que la
matière est effectivement valorisables
2e 2e et a bondi au delà de 30 ans est
globalement jusqu'à 100 ans
parfois il ya des zones d'incertitudes
on ne sait pas si les matières pourront
être valorisés mais il faut à ce moment
là là encore avoir une démarche de
prudence
s'il n'y a pas de filière industrielle
réaliste pour valoriser l'ensemble des
produits il faut anticiper une certaine
manière le lat et ne la requalification
en tant que déchet anticipé ça ne veut
pas dire qualifié ces matières en tant
que déchet il faut réfléchir à et si
elle était qualifiée en tant que déchet
que faut-il faire
que faut-il faire en termes de études
que faut-il faire en matière de
recherche de sites potentiels
donc on ne ne préconise pas une
requalification entre 30 et 100 ans on
dit il faut anticiper ce que il ya ça
prend beaucoup de temps je ne reviens
pas sur ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure
et puis dans le crois de la troisième
étape c'est pas si finalement il n'ya
pas de perspectives au delà de 100 ans
nous estimons que il faudrait
requalifier la madone en tant que déchet
donc ce sont des principes que nous
avons formulées dans le cadre de notre
avis ne sais pas c'est pas la dgec
et on espère la transition écologique
peut traduire ce qui les acceptent dans
le prochain pngmdr parce que ça conduira
bien évidemment à des prescriptions
particulières soit 31 de requalification
soit en termes d'anticipation
alors le sujet de l'uranium appauvri est
typiquement un sujet qui rentre dans tu
peux rentrer dans cette prise d' analyse
comme ça a été dit les stocks d'uranium
appauvri sont entreposés palais stable
l'histoire entreposer de la nouvelle
commission considérable c'est plus de
300 est en jeu c'est considérable les
despotes granum appauvri et aujourd'hui
il ya de la part des exploitants
il ya deux voies de valorisation sont
envisagées alors il ya une première voie
qui consisterait à utiliser cet uranium
appauvri dans des futurs réacteurs à
neutrons rapides pour lesquels
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de projet
concret puisque la recherche sur les
réacteurs à neutrons rapides comme vous
savez a été est repoussé le projet
astrid a été repoussé
donc le ca serait possible s'il était un
jour décidé de mettre en place une
filière à neutrons rapides qui présente
c'est clair un certain nombre
d'avantagés notamment en matière de
d'indépendance par rapport à
granum aux fournitures de minerai
d'uranium puisque il les acteurs à
neutrons rapides sont déçus peuvent être
des surgénérateurs et donc peuvent
s'affranchir des besoins en uranium
fichiers mais quand on regarde les
choses de manière approfondie on
s'aperçoit que la quantité d'uranium
appauvri qui pourraient être utiles pour
faire fonctionner un parc de rnr
équivalent au parc de réacteurs dont
dispose aujourd'hui donc c'est quand
même une trentaine
les quantités sont infimes
streiff est infinitésimal par rapport
aux 300 mille tonnes c'est très très peu
ces quelques pourcents et ça pourrait
donc conduire à assurer le
fonctionnement d'un parc de rnr pendant
plusieurs milliers d'années
donc ça ça n'a pas vraiment de sens par
rapport aux critères que j'ai indiqué le
serbe
le radium aguri pourrait être valorisé
mais le stock d'uranium est tel que ya
pratiquement une toute petite partie
infinitésimale qui serait valorisée donc
de notre point de vue si c'est ça la
filière de valorisation qui était
retenue il faudrait requalifier comme
déchets quand même une partie
substantielle de cette de cet uranium
appauvri et se préoccuper des conditions
de stockage de cet uranium à pau parce
que cette voie là ne permettra pas
d'utiliser tout le sport il ya une
deuxième voie qui vaille est
effectivement explorait parler a indiqué
parler les exploitants consisterait à
valoriser sur une case plus courte que
je crois que si ces sept ou huit années
le stock d'uranium appauvri en cas de
tension très forte sur le marché de
l'uranium mondial parce que
effectivement cet uranium appauvri
on peut le ré enrichissement ksa
permettrait d'avoir une certaine
indépendance par rapport aux
fluctuations sur le marché mondial et
prix d'uranium
ces brèves les procédés existent tout à
fait possible industriellement c'est
possible et la totalité du stock
d'uranium appauvri pour être valorisées
dans une période raisonnable dit cet
habitant donc cette voie là sur le lé
correspond à nos critères
sauf que la valorisation de ce stock
d'uranium appauvri
générerait du fait du ray enrichissement
à stocks équivalents en uranium très
appauvri dire que le processus
industriel conduit à ce que à l'issue du
ray en crèche sysmans de l'uranium
on conserve une partie très très très
très très riche très appauvri est donc
le problème du de la qualification de
déchets de cet uranium très très
appauvri et qui ne pourraient plus être
valorisés se posent aux rêves et donc
même dans cette deuxième option
il faut quand même réfléchir en
anticipation à la question de juste aux
cages voilà ce que je voulais dire sur
sur les principes que nous avons émis en
termes de gestion des matières
radioactives et répondre je crois à la
question concernant l'uranium appauvri
merci où il répond très complète alors
juste dans le cas où on langer été
coupée à ce moment là bas je ne jeûne je
ne connais pas les autres questions
on va me donner la main à olivier oui on
est très bien par dans juste pardon à
une question sur le financement de la
recherche que tu peux peut-être là
progrès je la prendrai il y en a une à
laquelle je peux répondre sur les
ressources humaines de l'asn
mais sur le président de la nuit vous
m'interrogez sur finalement le ce que
j'ai indiqué dans mon éditorial du
rapport annuel de la complexité quoi
sont des questions à traiter un exemple
c'est justement ce qu'on évoquait sur
l'évaluation de la la durée de vie des
des cuves
en fait il s'agit d'une certaine façon
de voir si au delà des des
démonstrations de sûreté d'origine qui
avait été fait on peut faire des calculs
en quelque sorte plus racine et cours
pour mettre en évidence des marges et
finalement exploiter les les cuves
au delà de ce qui avait été envisagé au
départ est donc évidemment ça nécessite
pas d donc des calculs plus fin et donc
des compétences plus plus importantes
pour ce faire autre exemple
de compétences pointues et rare c'est
par exemple ce dont on a besoin
justement pour assurer les contrôles
installation très spécifiques et très
unique comme une terre donc voilà voilà
deux exemples et nous avons mis en place
un processus en fait au sein de l'asn
pour fidéliser chercher à garder plus
longtemps nos personnels en leur
proposant des parcours de carrière de
façon à effectivement entretenir et
développer les compétences en interne
voilà c'est un exemple de deux mesures
que l'on prend on essaie de lui
naturellement de composer vous évoquiez
le nôtre visée qui est essentiellement
fait de corps de fonctionnaires on
essaie de composer au mieux avec les
règles et les contraintes qui sont les
nôtres c'est pas toujours évident mais
effectivement on prend toutes les
actions nécessaires
il y avait peut-être une autre question
également que je peux prendre sur le
béton des enceintes de confinement
simplement pour dire que ça n'est pas
afin là effectivement l'enceinte est un
composant de remplaçable elle participe
à la limitation des rejets naturellement
en cas d'accident en portant par contre
ça n'est pas un élément aussi dit
mentionnant un aussi crucial un peu que
les la cuve par rapport à l'évaluation
de la durée d'exploitation la durée de
fonctionnement des centrales nucléaires
parce que on peut améliorer lorsque
c'est nécessaire l'étanchéité des des
enceintes en béton en y apposant un
revêtement justement en revêtement
composite et df l'a déjà fait sur
différents réacteurs pour en améliorer
l'étanchéité
donc c'est pour ça que j'avais ce focus
plutôt sur les cuves que sur les que sur
les ensembles
bernard peut-être tu te laisses à ce
moment là la main sur sur la recherche
je vais reprendre merci je reprends donc
sur la recherche heure là l'asn à sa fin
dans deux missions sur la recherche qui
sont décrites dans le code de
l'environnement
donc notre mission consiste à assurer un
suivi des travaux de recherche et à
formuler des propositions des
recommandations sur les besoins en
recherche en matière de contrôle de la
sûreté nucléaire et de la
radioprotection
donc ces propositions sont communiqués à
la fois aux autorités
et elles sont communiqués au centre de
recherche pour qu'elle soit prise en
compte
bien évidemment donc nous avons formulé
à ce stade 3,3 à vie en recommandations
en 2012 2015 et 2018 et nous sommes en
train de préparer un avis alors nos
stratégies à ce stade
fort de ces avis ont si staal et faire
connaître
donc nous prenons nos patrons de
pèlerins nous en voir les centres de
recherche les organismes des camps
organisent deux cercles ministère de la
recherche
et nous allons présenter ses avis leur
contenu on pourrait jouer 1,29 effet une
influence pour que ces avis soient
prises en compte dans les appels à
projets on peut dire qu'il ya il ya eu
un certain nombre de résultats positifs
notamment sur des sujets comme le
vieillissement des aciers
quant à l'exposition aux faibles doses
les avis de l'asn ont été pris en compte
dans les travaux de recherche ou dans
les appels d'offres de recherche
mais on peut aussi constater qu'un
certain nombre de noms sujet qu'il
paraissait important d'acquisition des
connaissances pour pouvoir réaliser
notre mission donc n'ont pas été
suffisamment suivi d'effet
donc le jeu élément de faiblesse
finalement que l'on constate parce que
quand on discute avec des centres de
recherche souvent ils me disent oui
c'est intéressant mais quels sont les
moyens dont vous disposez pour aider à
travailler sur ces sujets le l'élément
de faiblesse principale c'est que l'asm
ne dispose d'aucun moyen financier pour
pouvoir
appuyer sa stratégie d' influence aucun
train et puis il ya des travaux de
recherche qui sont parfois beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus zone et ses filles ont des
travaux de recherche
certainement dans d'ampleur moindre qui
pourrait se réaliser sur sur deux ans
par exemple et qui nous aiderait
directement dans le cadre des décisions
que nous avons à prendre mais que nous
sommes les mieux à même à piloter parce
que nous ne connaissons parfaitement le
besoin que nous avons nous mêmes
identifiées et dans ce cas là évidemment
on peut s'interroger pourquoi
faudrait-il que l'on demande à d'autres
sont moins au fait un dut du sujet de
piloter une recherche dans nous avons
absolument besoin donc notre stratégie
en matière de recherche est bien
évidemment de continuer à faire avec
l'appui de notre comité scientifique
nous avons un comité scientifique à
l'asm d'identifier les besoins en
connaissances qui sont nécessaires pour
asseoir notre mission est d'avoir en
plus de ces avis et moyens pour pouvoir
influencer la recherche ou réaliser de
nous mêmes un certain nombre de
recherches pas donc le c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous avons nous avons
récemment dans le cadre de la réparation
loi de finances 2022 demandé à pouvoir
disposer d'une enveloppe financière qui
est modeste puisque nous avons demandé
trois cent mille euros pour pouvoir
notamment soutenir des projets de
recherche ciblée qui sont
complémentaires
autre vote recherche des grands
organismes et qui serait directement
utiles à l'asn
ça c'est la demande immédiate pour 2022
et notre ambition c'est pour 2023
une fois que nous aurons arrêté notre
prochain avis je pense fin 2021 2022 qui
est de pouvoir disposer d'un de crédit
qui seraient des crédits alors là
influences qui nous permettrait de
participer à des tours de table qui nous
permettrait de jouer d'avoir un effet de
levier sur les choix de thématiques de
recherche parce que nous apporterions
une part de financement auprès de
l'opérateur de recherche publique
voilà les la stratégie qui consiste
vraiment à disposer de moyens financiers
pour pouvoir réaliser des opérations
ciblées dans un premier temps et pour
pouvoir avoir un degré d' influence plus
fort dans les grands projets dans tous
les cas l'asn n'a bien évidemment pas
l'intention ni d'ailleurs pas
raisonnable et est pas sérieux de se
substituer aux grands organismes de
recherche dans le domaine de la sûreté
et de la radioprotection à m'en irai
scène de ces lois ou des sorties
recherche d'emploi médical s'agit bien
d'avoir une action complémentaire et
d'avoir un effet un moyen pour faire
jouer un effet louis merci monsieur le
président hu et trois cent mille euros
on est plus sage et plus des pilotes
mais de réussir deux carrés dans ce que
dans ce que vous demandez il y avait une
forme il est question que vous n'avez
pas pu entendre rien avait une
concernant la sous traitance et la façon
dont vous les processus de vigilance mis
en oeuvre sur ces sujets de la sous
traitance
il y avait une question sur votre
évaluation des alertes lancées par
récemment par des rapports de négawatt
et de greenpeace sur le fait que à peine
la moitié des mesures post fukushima
aurait été ont été mises en place
comment vous évaluez cela la mise en
oeuvre des mesures post fukushima
aujourd'hui une dizaine d'années après
il y avait une question sur sur
fessenheim et les les questions de
recyclage qui vont avec
je vous retrouver très précisément la
question dans quelques
l'instant mais déjà sur ces questions de
sous traitance sur la question de
démesure post-fukushima si vous pouvez
vous donner des éléments bon parce que
d'abord choc sur la sous traitance la
sous traitance est bien évidemment une
pratique tout à fait normal dans le
monde industriel et développé dans l'air
et la sous-traitance peut vraiment être
bénéfique pour pour la sûreté lorsque il
existe des compétences pointues qui ne
peuvent pas être entretenu à l'échelle
d'un exploitant mai mais que certains
prestataires peuvent développer en
france en france et parfois à
l'international est donc cette
compétence peut être très utile pour la
sûreté
elle est aussi nécessaire lorsque les
opérations qui sont à réaliser ne rentre
pas dans le coeur de métier de
l'exploitant cas il est tout à fait
naturel qu'ils s'adressent à des sous
traitants et ses sous-traitants peuvent
du fait de l'échelle du parc nucléaire
français
bien évidemment entretenir leurs
expériences et leurs compétences
le semble le point qui me semble
vraiment le plus important dans la sous
traitance qui a fait l'objet de mesures
en matière de réduction de la chaîne de
sous-traitance dans la boîte et au cv et
sous traitance en cascade sans en
maîtrise du niveau de sous traitance ont
été traités dans l'alba et le cv mais le
point le plus important me semble être
celui de la compétence
c'est clairement la compétence
d'exécution on le voit dans les
difficultés qui ont été rencontrés à la
presse sur le parc en service sur la
construction des oeuvres le point qui
peut peut être le coin de faiblesse la
compétence et cette compétence n'est pas
lié à la chaîne de sous traitance
donc il faut absolument que cette
compétence soit vérifié régulièrement
par le donneur d'ordres soit évalué soit
vérifiée notamment lorsqu'il fait le
choix de rld à nos prestataires ou
lorsque les prestataires dont pas
pratiquer d'activité dans le nucléaire
depuis longtemps en tous points de vue
là c'est ce que je soulignais tout à
l'heure le fait que les volumes de
travaux dans certains critères notamment
la mécanique en être multiplié par six
on est quelques années qui viennent avec
les travaux à réaliser sur les réacteurs
en exploitation
j'ai du réexamen c'était effectivement
un bon moyen de pouvoir entretenir cette
compétence de permettre aux prestataires
de recruter d'investir de former parce
qu'ils ont de la visibilité
or de nombreuses années je sais que les
réexamens de des 900 mégawatts va aller
jusqu à 2031 et et à partir de 2025 il y
aura le réexamen des réacteurs de 13 100
mégawatts
donc c'est un élément très important
c'est une opportunité pour la filière
nucléaire d'entretenir les compétences à
la fois bien sûr je fais exprès temps ce
qui est important aussi en termes
d'ingénierie et puis je fais les sous
traitants donc je pense que la sous
traitance est un élément fondamental et
nous avons et nous avons nous avons dans
le cadre de notre mission d'inspection
olivier le pied tout à l'heure nous
avons prévu bien évidemment aussi
réalisé des inspections chez les
fabricants et je fais des sous traitants
de manière à pouvoir évaluer et
contrôler cette compétence chez ces
opérateurs
alors on parle souvent je ne sais pas si
c'était dans la question mais on parle
souvent de la de l'exposition des sous
traitants et notamment de des soutras la
différence qu'il peut y avoir entre m
d'exposition entre les salariés d'edf et
des prestataires donc est clair que dès
les travailleurs des entreprises sous
traitantes sont soumis aux mêmes règles
de radioprotection que les salariés
d'edf c'est le cas du travail s'applique
à tous dans la différence en termes
d'exposition aux rayonnements ionisants
peut s'expliquer par la science de
tâches qui est confiée à c'est ce que
prétendent ils peuvent parfois être
exposés plus exposés que le personnel de
l'élève sabres en arrêt de tranche dans
des chantiers qui sont réalisés en zone
contrôlée travaux d'édification mais
aussi la pose des siècles d'échafaudages
par exemple la pose et la dépose et la
pose de qu'elle refuse tout ça ce sont
des les opérations qui sont souvent
traités et qui peuvent conduire les
salariés des entreprises sous-traitantes
à des expositions plus importante que
les salariés edf
oui mais
complètement sur le président et notre
la sous traitance est aussi invitée
récemment dans l'actualité dans le cadre
d'un scandale de documents falsifiés
pour les secours que pour certaines
entreprises pour une entreprise de sous
traitance en l'occurrence pour que des
soudeurs n'ayant pas tous les toutous
les certifications requises ou quelque
chose comme ça puisse intervenir à la
hague dont il y avait là que la question
du contrôle de la compétence dans la
chaîne de sous traitance qui est aussi
posée alors vous avez raison il ya la
question de la compétence mais il ya
aussi la question du risque de fraude
qui peut se poser et qui peut se poser
d'ailleurs pour l'ensemble des
opérateurs il peut y avoir la sous
traitance les pâtes à terre mais ça peut
se poser mais signe chez les exploitants
donc là vous faites directement appel
aux échos beau plan d'action qui a été
mis en oeuvre par l'asn ya quelques
années contre le risque de fraude
suite au constat qu'il avait été fait
notamment au creusot et ce plan et
comporte plusieurs types d'actions des
actions de renforcement du contrôle par
les exploitants eux-mêmes des contrôles
leurs prestataires qui pour croire les
documents que les justifications que les
prestataires fournissent ça peut parmi
les actions il ya aussi le recours à des
organismes de contrôle extérieur qui
permettent d'avoir un oeil indépendant
sur les contrôles qui seront réalisés
évidemment l'asn réalise des inspections
sur ce thème vis-à-vis du risque de
fraude
et puis nous avons mis en place un
recueil de systèmes pardon de recueil
des signalements sur un portail internet
qui sont ouverts aux lanceurs d'alerté
dans toutes ses dispositions qui sont
maintenant opérationnels qui fonctionne
permettent effectivement de mieux
identifier
même si on ne voit pas tout s'éclaire de
mieux identifier les anomalies
est ce que le frotte donc le sait le
notamment notamment vis-à-vis du
renforcement des dispositions mises en
place parce décrétant le cas que vous
citez récent chez renault puisque ce
tutorat nous il ya détecté qu'un
prestataire unique et et croates
s'étaient ils réaliser des opérations de
soudage
sur son usine de la hague avait
effectivement falsifié les documents les
procès verbaux de qualification des
soudeurs donc ça c'est effectivement un
des sujets principaux
en termes de risques de fraudes c'est la
modification des documents notamment de
qualification pour les soudeurs pour les
contrôleurs non destructif qui est un
sujet à très hautes exigences donc le
aura nos à détecter nous a déclaré
immédiatement cet incident il a vérifié
en interview dont les autres sites
doisneau si cette entreprise croître
étaient intervenus ils ont le même
communiqué cette information à
l'extérieur donc les risques de fraude
concerne essentiellement les documents
qui attestent des qualifications
concerne aussi les documents qui
attestent d'un contrôle parfois sous
contrôle et attester comme ayant été
fait et il n'est pas fait et puis il ya
des députés des fraudes sur sur la sur
l'identité des personnels les noms sont
changés pour pouvoir bénéficier de
benfica ça ce sont des écarts les plus
fréquents sont des merci beaucoup donc
la question à la question sur la mise en
oeuvre des mesures post fukushima sur
l'ensemble du parc
alors suite aux évaluations
complémentaires de sûreté qui ont été
réalisées après fukushima il ya eu il ya
eu un programme de travail un très très
très très important qui a été phase et
c'est à dire il ya il ya des premières
modifications qui ont été demandés et
qui correspondait à la consolidation des
dispositifs qui existait sur les sites
pour faire face à une perte
d'alimentation électrique totale sur un
site pour faire face à une perte de
change froides aux patchs principe des
dispositifs mobiles par exemple lafarge
qui existent aussi sa faim d'edf mais
qui existe aussi chez renault tout ça ce
sont des discussions qui ont été mises
dans un premier temps elles sont été
mise en place les actions
opérationnelles
il ya eu aussi une deuxième étape qui a
cumulé
de consolidation des installations
elles-mêmes qui a été définie et qui a
été je dirais en grand majorité réalisés
totalement une phase une deuxième phase
qui consistait à faire finalement je
simplifie les affaires de manière dure
ce qui avait été mis en place de manière
mobile pour que ces dispositifs
supplémentaires soient présents sur
chacun des sites et ne fasse pas appel à
des unités mobiles pour les mettre en
oeuvre
ça c'est la deuxième phase et n'est pas
terminé il ya eu des retards mais des
retards qui sont relativement bien
identifiés qui peuvent pas s'expliquer
pour des raisons industrielles ya eu par
exemple un retard sur les tuche sur le
diesel d'ultime secours à battre en
place chez edf ce retard a été
maintenant rattraper complet mais là
certaines opérations qui ne sont pas
encore mises en oeuvre par exemple les
centres de crise bunkérisé qui ne sont
pas dans ceux en service chez tous les
exploitants néanmoins en attendant des
exploitants ont vérifié que les centres
de crise actuelle pouvait résister à des
aléas extrême donc il ya quelques écarts
mais qui sont justifiés ou qui sont
explicables sur cette deuxième phase
et puis il ya une troisième phase qui
est une phase à plus long terme qui
correspond à des modifications d'ampleur
plus importantes et ont été prévus dans
le cadre du réexamen de sûreté d rect
notamment le 4e re examen des réacteurs
de 900 mégawatts ou de 13 cents le
troisième un examen des réacteurs du
palier n4
donc là on est dans une phase de
consolidation long terme qui est qui
avait été prévu comme devant être
interfacé avec leurs examens bien
évidemment le réexamen est en cours et
donc cette phase là n'était pas terminée
globalement nous estimons que tels que
des cartes près les exploitants au plus
tôt suivi le calendrier qui était prévu
suite aux évaluations complémentaires de
sûreté et réalisé post et est-ce que
escale à la mise en oeuvre quand est-ce
que ce programme de mise à jour
on peut évaluer sa fin jeanne la 3d la
troisième phase est cadencé avec les
examens et donc c'est ça doit être 2031
pour les réacteurs de 900 mégawatts et
2035 pour les réacteurs de 13 100
mégawatts olivier je ne sais pas si tu
as voilà les dates
merci il y avait là la question sur la
question sur sur fessenheim et la
question du recyclage des générateurs de
vapeur qu'est ce qu'on peut dire là
dessus ce qui est des difficultés
particulières est ce que c'est quelque
chose là-dessus et mais avant emily
cariou à une question qui porte sur la
question que vous nous venons d'aborder
mais est-ce parce que vous nous parlez
donc des trois phases mais il me semble
quand même que la troisième phase est là
elle entraîne des engagements financiers
beaucoup plus lourd que les premières
alors peut-être que je me trompe mais
est ce que vous pourriez nous donner un
peu un ordre d'idée parce qu'en fait la
3 qui conditionne la faisabilité et le
respect des calendriers c'est aussi le
fait de pouvoir financer les travaux
donc il me semble que la troisième phase
elle elle est très très lourd je n'ai
pas de chiffre je ne sais pas si
quelqu'un à l'asn en main et peut
répondre plus précisément à votre
question madame la députée ce que je
peux dire c'est que bien évidemment ces
travaux qui sont prévus
programmé dans le cadre de l'examen
figure dans le plan grand carénage d'edf
ils doivent y figurer puisqu'ils sont
donc ce grand carénage comporte un
débouche sur une enveloppe financière de
près de 50 milliards en euros courants
qui a été actualisée récemment ces
travaux figurent figure quel est leur
part exacte ul est actuellement real je
n'en sais rien je ne sais pas je ne fais
pas répondre à cette question je sais
pas si quelqu'un répondre à cette
question et nous si quelqu'un souhaite
d'ailleurs donner un complément par
rapport à ce que je viens de dire par
rapport à ce phasage et à la nature des
travaux se passe ici
cadets mercier qui est commissaire à
l'asn souhaite dire quelque chose sur le
basque ou shima au regard d'objectifs de
sûreté croissant on peut me gardant de
khl a dit la première phase c'était
vraiment veut très réactive et la
deuxième phase a été plus pour augmenter
la résilience des organisations et des
installations et la phase 3 qui reste un
peu une étape complémentaire pour
ajouter une ligne de défense est
l'objectif c'est bien prévenir les
rejets massifs et les effets durables
sur l'environnement
et ça constitue absolument un objectif
du réexamen et 12 c'est pour ça que
c'est en lien avec leurs examens et donc
de lancer dedans il ya bien le rappel de
la fonction récupérateur de corium au
cas où le corps fonds pour éviter la
contamination des nappes est aussi le
refroidissement de l'enceinte pour
éviter les rejets
on vous voit de la nature et le niveau
de sûreté atteint à la suite de ses fans
et pas du tout la même et la faillite en
lien avec leur examen permet de se
rapprocher des objectifs de sûreté des
réacteurs de génération iii d'où le
passage en termes d'objectifs croissant
de ce petit ok merci pour ces bons oui
allez-y wilbaux net pour trouver des
solutions effectivement des travaux très
importants effectivement bernard de
réussite et l'échéance de 2035
il ya une partie des travaux qui sont
faits en quatrième visite décennale pour
les réacteurs de 900 mégawatts mais pour
certains aussi quatre ans après la
deuxième visite décennale puisque c'est
ces phases et sur sur deux arrêts compte
tenu de l'importance des travaux et donc
ça nous amène effectivement y compris
pour ses réacteurs la halle échéance de
2035 ce que je peux ajouter également
c'est que les vérifications à faire à
l'issue de fukushima elle avait été
définie par un cahier des charges commun
à l'échelle européenne justement à
nouveau par cette association aidera
donc j'ai parlé tout à l'heure quand on
regarde où on en est justement entre les
différents pays
la france n'est pas en retard malgré le
fait qu'il ya un nombre très important
de deux réacteurs à modifier et au
contraire sur sur ce que civique à des
artistes et appelé la troisième phase
ce sont plutôt des modifications que peu
de pays ont décidé de faire donc voilà
alors peut-être sur la question des
générateurs de vapeur de fessenheim
mélange effectivement pas été tout à
fait clairs tout à l'heure lorsque j'ai
parlé de la mise en place d'un processus
industriel de valorisation des déchets
métalliques f1 c'est effectivement ce
projet qui est envisagé sur le site de
fessenheim et qui pourrait être sur le
site de tricastin également tf1 a mis en
avant ces deux options mais l'option
privilégiée je crois c'est fessenheim
c'est ce projet industriel à qui
permettrait de valoriser le métal des
générateurs de vapeur de fessenheim qui
serait rendu dans cette installation et
pourrait être valorisée donc c'est
l'opération est directement lié à aux
projets de textes qui ont été diffusés
récemment qui font suite au débat public
sur le cinquième plan et qui prévoit la
possibilité de déroger législation
actuelle alimentation actuelle pour
valoriser les déchets tf1 mais
métallique et uniquement les déchets de
tf1 métallique ce sur quoi nous sommes
nous sommes sûrs effectivement
favorables d'accord
merci beaucoup je reviens sur juste pour
clarifier pour être sûr de bien
clarifier les choses sur ces questions
de deux mesures post fukushima
le document auquel je faisais allusion
qui a circulé document en date du 5 mars
2021 rapport publié par l'institut par
l'institut négawatt
parlant des mesures de renforcement du
parc nucléaire français dix ans après
fukushima donc dans ce rapport qui
interpellent et qui a un jugement assez
sévère sur certains un certain retard
évoque le fait que dans le plan initial
la plupart des mesures était prévu pour
une mise en oeuvre sur sur échelle une
décennie qu'ensuite le le ca a été
rééchelonnée sur une sur une troisième
phase avant trois phases dont une phase
bien plus longue pour permettre à
l'opérateur de s'adapter je cite un
élément du éléments du rapport fin de la
prise de position donc des auteurs
d'abord il insiste sur le fait qu'à un
retard sur la construction et la mise en
oeuvre des dizaines d'ultime secours les
fameux des us que vous que vous évoquez
en 2020 il rapport alors que certains
des us sont mises en service de
nombreuses avaries sont constatées
notamment des déboires de feu le
redémarrage et des us en juin 2020 et df
déclarés disponibles des us de six
réacteurs aucun avis d'incident n'est
publiée sur le site de l'asn qui ne
communiquent pas cet événement malgré
une consultation publique menée le même
mois pour autoriser un nouveau report
d'échéances mise en service certains des
us l'asm décide une nouvelle fois de
modifier ses prescriptions pour
s'adapter aux capacités de l'exploitant
et repousse l'échéance pour la centrale
de cattenom flamanville et palluel les
derniers réacteurs valeur des glaces
disponibles sont donc les réacteurs 1 et
2 de la centrale de palluel avec une
échéance finalement fixé à fin février
je vous livre le rapport ici des
éléments de rapports brut
ces histoires de savoir quelles sont vos
réactions ou qu'est-ce que comment vous
estimez vous ce sera tard
les vielles peut-être là en fait on
n'avait pas fixé à l'origine d'échéance
sur l'ensemble des aspects donc pense
que c'est pas réellement exact de dire
que tout était prévu sous une décennie
et ensuite il ya eu la phase iii parce
que c'est pas comme ça que ça s'est
passé c'était vrai par contre c'est que
il ya eu des difficultés dans le
déploiement d'antennes dans la dans la
dans la construction des dizaines de
greens secours sur les 32 réacteurs de
900 mégawatts et qui ont été les
premiers à le passer et en fait on a
dîné sur d'autres réacteurs et en fait
on a on a accepté
oui un report d'échéances compte tenu
des difficultés industrielles
le justicier et quelque part vérifier
aussi par nos propres inspecteurs si
vous voulez à un moment donné on a
considéré qu'il valait mieux donner un
peu plus de temps à aider f
il avait acquis une question encore une
fois de faisabilité mais mais il valait
aussi mieux donner un peu plus de temps
pour que de ces travaux soit bien fait
plutôt que de finir dans la
précipitation donc là effectivement au
bout de dix ans ce qu'on peut dire c'est
que ces travaux sur les diesels d'ultime
secours sont faits et permettre aux
centrales nucléaires de résister a
finalement d'être plus robuste à la
perte d'alimentation électrique dans le
cadre de ce qu'on appelle les accidents
de dimensionnement
bien bien bien bien reçu donc en tout
cas ce que vous dites c'est que l'afer
est de votre côté documenté que la
solution la plus celle qui à la fin à
man au plus haut niveau de sécurité
d'une façon qui est effectivement et qui
peut être qui peut être mise en oeuvre
et celles qui aboutit finalement d'une
part par rapport à deuxième d'abord par
qui aboutit à cet étalement sur trois
phases qui viennent prendre en compte
les grandes opérations de maintien sur
les sur les réacteurs donc 2031 pour les
900 mégawatts 2035 pour les 1300
mégawatts et d'autre part il ya ces
retards effectivement sur la sur la
deuxième phase dont vous l'estimez qui
sont qui se comprennent et qu'ils sont
sous contrôle
maintenant on est arrivé donc pour
l'aider us en particulier ils sont tous
mise en oeuvre maintenant oui peut-être
juste sur les sur les lattes c'est aussi
2035 pour les réacteurs de 900 mégawatts
parce qu'en réalité une partie des
modifications et nous en oeuvre quatre
ans au deuxième ce qu'on appelle le
deuxième lot de modifications quatre ans
après la visite décennale hockey 2031
c'est la fin mais c'est la fin des
visites décennales et il faut compter 4
en plus bien reçu bien noté je pense que
nous arrivons à l'ats que nous arrivons
à l'aboutissement des questions je me
tourner vers ma collègue émilie cariou
vers les collègues parlementaires qu'ils
sont aux visioconférences côté de beaune
aussi d'opa de nouvelles questions
nous avons pris sensiblement plus de
temps que ce qui était prévu et je vous
en remercie monsieur le président
monsieur le directeur général pour votre
disponibilité là
pour la patience avec laquelle vous avez
répondu à toutes nos questions et pour
le patient ce qui est nécessaire qui
fait partie de vos culs partie de vos de
tout ce que vous devez mettre en oeuvre
pour qu'à chaque fois cet échange avec
avec le parlement puisse aller dans le
fond des dossiers
on a bien noté certains des messages qui
sont venus de façon récurrente dans
votre discours sur l'importance du plan
de ressources humaines la capacité à
faire et à mettre en oeuvre les
opérations complexes à venir
d'opérations qui ont tendance à être de
plus en plus complexes sur l'importance
de choix d'orientation de choix
stratégiques à faire sur lesquels l'état
doit se prononcer assez rapidement et
comme vous nous litière des choix
décisifs qui doivent être pris dans les
dents les cinq années à venir
bien bien noter aussi ce que vous nous
dites sur les questions de recherche et
l'importance pour vous d'avoir un volet
de financement de moyens que vous pouvez
mettre en oeuvre pour la recherche
si modeste soit ces moyens est entendue
qui viennent seulement en complément
d'autres pour participer aux tables et
pas pour mener des recherches en propre
sur les marges sur les cuves sur la
fusion sur les mesures post fukushima
sur la valorisation
la libération dans certains cas des
déchets de très faible activité sur les
filières à neutrons rapides sur les
petits réacteur modulaire sur les
questions de contrôle des ressources
humaines et la sous-traitance l'ensemble
la varité complexité des questions ont
bien montré que nous sommes ici sur un
sur un sujet dans la technicité est
considérable et bien montré encore une
fois combien il est important d'avoir
une autorité de contrôle
capable de jouer son rôle en
indépendance avec la plus grande
compétence et avec la plus grande
détermination et l'importance également
de pouvoir mener régulièrement cette ces
opérations ces séances au cours
desquelles vos rapports et vos
conclusions sont discutées sont
présentés à la représentation nationale
et plus généralement plus généralement
au parlement avec un grand merci pour la
le soin la qualité avec laquelle vous
préparez à chaque fois votre rapport ces
auditions et pour votre disponibilité
monsieur le président monsieur le
directeur général c'est avec plaisir que
nous continuerons ce partenariat de long
terme institutionnels inscrit dans la
loi et qui est extrêmement important
pour que l'office puisse très
régulièrement discutée être éclairée par
votre analyse sur le sujet un grand
merci au nom de l'ensemble du 2 au nom
de l'ensemble de l'office et on angle
ensemble du parlement tous nos souhaits
pour la suite de l'accomplissement de
vos missions qui sont à la fois délicate
est fondamentale pour la pour un france
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les parlementaires
merci monsieur le président pour votre
conclusion et nous restons bien
évidemment à la disposition de l'opex si
souhaitiez que nous approfondissions tel
ou tel sujet
je pense notamment peut-être la
discussion que nous avons eue sur le
pngmdr dans le cadre des étapes à vue
si vous souhaitez nous pourrions bien
évidemment venir vous en parler oui il y
à en parler
vous avez complètement raison de ce
président en fait il y a les deux
missions qui sont en cours
d'une part la mission sido carew sur le
pngmdr d'autre part la mission gaccio
pieds noirs sur l'état de la recherche
d'orientation stratégique française
après l'abandon de d'astrid l'une et
l'autre de ces missions donneront lieu
bien sûr à des rapports de l'opex tu as
des as des séances à des séances dans
lesquelles nous aborderons tous ces
sujets et dans lesquels votre expertise
sans votre expertise sera précieuse et
votre contribution au débat public à
l'occasion également nous espérons
effectivement que l'or pour l'évaluation
du pngmdr tout bêtement nous sommes
coincés par l'absence de publication de
ce psg mdr par l'état tout est prêt pour
que dans l'espace deux ans quelques
semaines après la après la publication
de ce de ce rapport nous puissions après
publication du plan du puissions rendre
le rapport les conclusions et organiser
le débat mais pour l'instant nous devons
évaluer une stratégie qui n'est
officiellement pas connu et on retrouve
hors tombe exactement sur ce que vous
évoquez sur les échéances stratégique
dans lesquelles l'état est en retard
très clairement
[Musique]